did you know that Facebook removed 2.29
billion content pieces from their
website after a record number of
complaints regarding hacked accounts
even the mighty Facebook cannot secure
its systems 100% such is a situation
when it comes to cyber security based on
recent events and future predictions
cyber crimes will cost organizations
worldwide a whopping $10.5 trillion
coming from just $3.5 trillion in 2050
so you can understand why it should not
come as a surprise that professionals
trained in cyber security are in skyh
high demand and will be for the
foreseeable future so what's better than
staying ahead of the curve and getting
traded in cyber security subscribe at
simply learn of course since we upload
Tech related content every day hit the
Bell icon to get notified whenever we
drop a new video today's video will be a
full course on cyber security for 2023
starting from the basics to the advanced
topics he provide a small introduction
to cyber security followed by explainers
regarding the career scope in this
domain and the job roles offered after
covering a few cyber security skills we
will learn about ethical hacking and
network masking techniques like VPN and
proxies further we delve into various
attacks like Doos attacks SQL injection
and cross-site scripting with live
demonstrations that you can carry out on
your own system for practice after
learning a bit more about different
cyber attacks we will learn about
cryptography covering topics like
encryption famous algorithms like RSA
and AES and hashing algorithms like s256
algorithm next we look at the Linux
based operating systems that you can use
for ethical hacking like K Linux and
parro security we then further dive into
some of the tools that cyber security
analysts use to secure their systems
finally we cover the industry's most
well-known certifications followed by a
series of interview questions to prepare
you for your first job in cyber security
so let's get
started meet an she often shops from
www. shoppingcart tocom she has her
information like email ID address and
credit card details saved on the website
to enable a faster and hassle-free
shopping
experience the required information is
stored in a server one day an received
an email which stated her eligibility
for a special discount voucher from
shopping cart.com in order to receive
the coupon code she was asked to fill in
her shopping cart.com account
credentials this didn't seem fishy to
her at the time as she thought it was
just an account verification step little
did she realize the danger she would be
facing she was knocked off her feet when
a substantial amount of money was wiped
off her account how do you think this
happened well yes the email she received
was fake an's shopping cart.com account
witnessed unauthorized access from a
third party this type of attack is known
as a Cyber attack and the person who
carries it out is called a hacker could
Ann have prevented this attack
indeed she could have with the help of
cyber security cyber security involves
techniques that help in securing various
digital components networks data and
computer systems from unauthorized
digital access there are multiple ways
to implement cyber security depending on
the kind of network you are connected to
and the type of cyber attacks you are
prone to so let's take a look at the
various cyber attacks that an could have
been exposed to one of the most most
common types of cyber attacks is a
malware attack like Trojan adwar and
spyware to name a few had an downloaded
any suspicious attachments online her
system could have gotten corrupted by
certain malicious viruses embedded
within the attachments next is a fishing
attack the type of Cyber attack which an
experienced here the hacker usually
sends fraudin emails which appear to be
coming from a legitimate Source this is
done to install malware or to Ste
sensitive data like credit card
information and login
credentials another type of attack is
the man in the middle attack here the
hacker gains access to the information
path between an's device and the website
server the Hacker's computer takes over
an's IP address by doing so the
communication line between an and the
website is secretly
intercepted this commonly happens with
unsecured Wi-Fi networks and also
through malware password attack is one
of the easiest ways to hack a system
here Ann's password could have been
cracked by using either common passwords
or trying all possible alphabetical
combinations to prevent future cyber
attacks an sought to implement a few
cyber security practices first she
installed a firewall as the name
suggests it is a virtual wall between
an's computer and the internet firewalls
filter the incoming and outgoing traffic
from your device to safeguard your
network and they can either be software
applications or Hardware reinforcements
secondly and implemented honey Poots
just like how flowers attract bees dummy
computer systems called honeypots are
used to attract attackers these systems
are made to look vulnerable in order to
deceive attackers and this in turn
defends the real system in addition to
these she also decided to use unique
alpha numeric passwords antivirus
software and started avoiding males from
unknown own senders that was Ann's story
cyber attacks are not just confined to
individuals but also to public and
private organizations the cyber attacks
carried out in such places are more
deadly and they result in colossal
losses motives of such attacks are many
starting from tampering with crucial
data to monetary gains let's have a look
at a few of the cyber attacks that
companies are subjected to various
public sector organizations and large
corporations face the advanced
persistent threat a in this form of
attack hackers gain access to networks
for a prolonged period in order to
continuously gain confidential
information companies also witnessed the
denial of service attack where networks
are flooded with traffic which in turn
leaves legitimate service requests
unattended a variant of this is the
distributed denial of service DDOS
attack when multiple systems are used to
launch the attack when a hacker
manipulates a standard SQL query in a
database driven website it is known as a
SQL injection attack by doing so hackers
can view edit and delete tables from
databases amidst a plethora of cyber
attacks it is indeed a challenge for
organizations with several networks and
servers to ensure complete Security this
is not an easy task and to help with
this cyber secur professionals are hired
to work on identifying cyber threats and
securing a company's Network there there
are multiple job roles in the field of
cyber security if hacking fascinates you
then the role of an ethical hacker is
something to be explored such
professionals try to exp Network's
vulnerabilities just like how a hacker
would do but only to identify those
vulnerabilities and resolve them for
protection against an actual Cyber
attack but if you are looking to design
robust security structures then the role
of a security architect is more apt a
chief information security officer ciso
plays a crucial role in Enterprise
security and is entrusted with the
overall safety of the information in an
organization now there are several
reasons as to why you should learn cyber
security here we have the top 10 reasons
for the same at number 10 the reason we
have is basic requirements there is a
wrong notion that building a career in
cyber security is daunting well it is
not a fancy college degree is not at all
that it takes to become become a
successful cyber security professional
you can Venture into the domain of cyber
security with some basic knowledge of it
and with an authorized cyber security
certification the overall eligibility
Criterion for the cyber security domain
is relaxing across the world it
professionals with cyber security
certifications are known to receive
higher salary packages certifications
are always given extra vitage in the
infos field and it opens doors to bigger
opportunities these cyber security
certifications can be opted by anyone as
the eligibility for these are very basic
cyber security certifications train
professionals and thus helps in Bridging
the Gap between the supply and demand of
skilled cyber security
professionals so don't take a step back
from learning cyber security thinking it
is a tedious process if you are a
fresher or a professional you can go
ahead with just these basic
requirements before moving on to our
next reason here is a question for you
all
how many of you like mathematics please
let us know in the comment section below
I'm sure not everyone loves mathematics
and that is completely okay when it
comes to learning cyber
security and our ninth reason is
mathematics is not a concern for
learning cyber
security many of us find mathematics
challenging some have the aptitude for
dealing with numbers and some don't and
for those who don't they find it
difficult to proceed with a career that
has math
involved however you can take your
decision without any worries when it
comes to cyber security as the domain of
cyber security does not involve
mathematics so if maths is not your
strong point then choosing to learn
cyber security is a great choice this
can definitely be a relief to many
instead you can get acquainted with
networking network security control and
coding to build a career in cyber
security our eighth reason is that cyber
security is a profession that helps
achieve the greater good cyber security
consists of a set of measures and
approaches that help companies and
individuals data from being compromised
and
stolen cyber Security Professionals have
defended organizations from several
deadly cyber attacks that aimed at
jeopardizing an organization's
confidentiality integrity and
availability cyber crimes are currently
on their rise with different types of
cyber attacks the threat to
organizations and individuals alike is
only growing by the day government
agencies police forces and cyber crime
cells are tackling this threat however
there is more requirement for skilled
cyber security professionals who can
protect data and work for the greater
good therefore if you want to bring
about a positive impact and a meaningful
difference to the society we live in
then learning cyber security is a great
choice our seventh reason is that you
get to travel the
world who doesn't love to travel the
globe learning cyber security is a great
reason especially for those of you who
aspire to travel the world with the lack
of cyber Security Professionals in the
world there are plenty of opportunities
for skilled experts to travel overseas
to Showcase their cyber security skills
which are in high demand The increased
demand for cyber Security Professionals
is not just restricted to one area but
to the entire world there are several
employment opportunities for cyber
Security Professionals across the globe
so learning Cy security can open new
doors for you overseas as well our sixth
reason is very interesting and that is
the fact that you get to work with
secret agencies and high-profile
ones like other
professionals cyber Security
Professionals also have the opportunity
to work with several prestigious
multinational companies and big giants
like Google Dell Accenture and others
however a cyber security professional's
career opportunities can go beyond mes
and they might get the opportunity to
work with top government secret agencies
like mosad NSA Nia FBI and so on so what
are you waiting for become a cyber
security expert and showcase your skills
to grab the chance to work with these
top agencies our fifth reason is it is
never too late to begin with there are
very few professions that give you the
Liberty to begin late and one such
profession is cyber security it is never
too late to realize that you want to
become a cyber security expert many
people work as cyber Security
Professionals even after the retirement
if they have a good knowledge about
it you could also join cyber security
courses that train you irrespective of
your
age as long as you have good cyber
security skills there is no need to
worry about job security however late it
is our fourth reason is cyber security
is an evergreen industry cyber security
has gradually become and Evergreen
industry in the current times with the
onset of the co 19 pandemic businesses
are moving online and shifting to cloud
storage the demand for cyber security is
at its
peak there is a high demand for cyber
Security Experts who can Safeguard
Digital Data hence we can be rest
assured that cyber security is here to
stay and this domain is only going to
grow in the coming
years according to cyber security
Ventures the number of Internet users
will hit a whooping 6 billion by
2022 these numbers speak volumes and
this reveals the growing demand for
cyber Security Professionals across the
globe digitalization is taking place
across several
Industries a cyber security expert finds
opportunities in every field as every
organization wants to be secure on the
digital front so now is the right time
if you are looking to learn and start a
career in cyber security before moving
to our top three reasons to learn cyber
security here's some crucial information
for you
all as you know with relevant
certifications you can grow your cyber
security career and here we are to help
you with that you can check out Simply
learns cyber security expert master's
program to equip you with the necessary
skills to become an expert in this
rapidly growing
domain training for highly short after
certifications like CompTIA Security
Plus CH CIS M and cissp is at the
Forefront of this course preparing you
for the industry's best jobs so what are
you waiting for get certified with
simply loar and grow your career in
cyber security
today so our third reason to learn cyber
security is because of the plenty of job
opportunities it offers according to the
US Bureau of Labor Statistics the
employment of information security
analyst is projected to grow 33% from
2020 to 2030 much faster than the
average for all
occupations with the world turning
digital there is a dire need for
companies to hire cyber Security Experts
who can protect and Safeguard sensitive
data as firms work to improve their
cyber security structure they are also
hiring several cyber Security Experts to
design Implement and maintain the Cyber
Security
Solutions cyber security jobs are not
limited to the it domain many secur
prity positions are found at companies
outside of it including Industries like
Media Sports or Finance to name a few
this emphasizes on the fact that a cyber
security export is exposed to several
job opportunities from different types
of companies across the
globe our second reason for you to learn
cyber security is the good salary
package it
offers salaries play a crucial part in
any job that you undertake isn't it
every individual likes to to get duly
rewarded for their work and cyber
security is one such domain that
provides fat
paychecks cyber Security Experts are the
individuals who have come to the rescue
with the unprecedented rise in cyber
crimes across the world organizations
are willing to pay Skyhigh salaries for
these cyber Security Experts there is a
lack of skilled cyber Security
Professionals and this is another reason
cyber Security Experts are paid
well the salaries of cyber Security
Professionals are St expected to grow in
the coming times owing to the high
demand salaries and cyber security have
a high growth potential and if you are a
skilled cyber security professional you
can always negotiate your
salary finally a top reason to learn
cyber security is that you will have a
job that never gets boring and a domain
that offers unlimited potential for
personal
growth several times individuals find
themselves lost in their career due to
lack of challenging Alles due to their
mundane work and also due to stagnation
at work these reasons play a major role
when it comes to a professional quitting
their job however a job rule in cyber
security tackles these reasons to an
extent and that is why we have this
reason at number one cyber security is a
domain that is constantly evolving and
so are the nature of cyber attacks
hackers are always trying to develop new
methods to get to your data they develop
new exploits regularly and hence as a
cyber security professional you will
face interesting challenges to find
Optimal Solutions for new exploits you
will have new puzzles to solve a cyber
security career is not going to be
stale along with failures you will also
be exposed to new and interesting
discoveries to keep yourself updated in
this field and to tackle cyber attacks
you should be in a position to outsmart
the hackers being in the field of cyber
security allows you to constantly
upskill and enhance your knowledge and
experience it also ensures that your
Learning Journey will never stop with
the world turning virtual cyber attacks
are constantly flooding new headlines Co
19 accelerated the current digital
transformation and the year 2020
witnessed several data breaches since
technology has become more intertwined
with our daily lives it is no surprise
that the need for skilled cyber Security
Professionals is increasing on that note
he every everyone welcome yet to another
exciting video by simply learn which
will take you through the top cyber
security career options available today
but before we begin if you're new here
and haven't subscribed already make sure
to hit the Subscribe button and that
Bell icon for interesting Tech videos
every day there is a significant lack of
skilled cyber security professionals who
can tackle the cyber security challenges
faced daily hence a career in cyber
security is demanding and equally
rewarding finding the right career path
path in the cyber security industry
isn't always easy here we are here to
help you with that there are a few
prerequisites for a career in cyber
security the basic one being a
bachelor's degree in a subject relating
to cyber security however if you don't
have a relevant degree you can always
take up relevant cyber security
certifications and Kickstart your cyber
security Journey a few other skills like
networking knowledge of operating
systems and Cloud security are required
to start and grow your cyber SEC career
you can check out our video on the top
five cyber security skills to no more
cyber security jobs vary from entry
level to Executive management and
everything in between there are several
cyber security pads available today it
is best if you start with entry level
and then move on to the next level with
the help of certifications and relevant
experience here let us have a look at
the top five cyber security job roles
today the first job role is that of a
network engineer Network Engineers
construct and administer a company's
computer networks they are responsible
for installing configuring and
supporting Network equipment they also
configure and maintain firewalls
switches and routers this entry-level
cyber security job can help you start
your journey to become an ethical hacker
the annual average salary of a network
engineer in the US is
$85,900 th000 rupees second on our list
is information security analyst as an
information security analyst your
primary duty is to protect sensitive
information information security
analysts create and Implement plans for
preventing cyber attacks they monitor
data access and ensure compliance with
policies depending on the Cyber threat
they decide if it has to be resolved or
escalated further in the US an
information security analyst earns $
89,1 140 annually and in India they earn
64275 rupees third on our list is
ethical hacker they're also known as
penetration testers they are Network
Security Consultants who identify and
exploit system vulnerabilities just like
how a hacker would do they probe and
test the network using various
penetration tools and software they also
design new penetration tools and
document the test results in the US a
certified ethical hacker earns around
$93,000 on an annual average basis and
in India they make around 5 lakh rupees
the fourth job role that we are going to
talk about is security architect
security Architects research and plan
the security elements for their
organizations they design robust
security structures that are capable of
preventing malware attacks a security
architect approves the installation of
routers VPN and firewalls their duties
go beyond just architecture building and
including formulating company procedures
guidelines and user guides security
architects in the US make a handsome sum
of
$124,000 a year on an average and in
India they make nearly 21 lakh 80,000
rupees and finally fifth on our list is
Chief Information Security Officer ciso
they are senior level officers in an
organization they ensure the safety of
the information they develop Implement
and maintain information security and
risk management programs they also
interact with stakeholders and regularly
brief them with information security
concerns the average annual salary of a
chief information security officer in
the states is a whopping
$165,000 annually and in India it is 22
lak 22,0 845 rupees several companies
are looking for skilled cyber Security
Professionals Phillips seamons Google
Microsoft and GE to name a few with
passion the right amount of experience
and relevant certifications you can grow
your cyber security career you can check
out Simply learn cyber security expert
Masters program to equip you with the
necessary skills needed to become an
expert in this rapidly growing domain
this course will help you learn various
methods as to how you can protect your
infrastructure secure your data run risk
analysis achieve compliance and much
more according to cyber crime magazine
by cyber security Ventures globally
there would be nearly 3.5 million unfill
cyber security jobs by 2021 and the
number of Internet users will hit a
whopping 6 billion by
2022 these numbers speak volumes and
this shows the growing demand for cyber
Security Professionals across the globe
now that you know the high demand for
cyber Security Professionals let us help
you start your cyber security career by
bagging the right skill
set many of you out there might be
waiting to become a cyber security
professional but are unsure of how to go
about it and what skills you would need
to get a cyber security job not to worry
we are here to help you with that after
extensive research we have come up with
the top five skills that will help you
get into the field of cyber security
let's have a look at these skills
individually first we have networking
and system
administration the number one skill you
need to have to enter the field of cyber
security is computer networking
networking is the backbone of the
internet it is imperative that you have
an in-depth understanding of networking
to start a career in cyber security a
network is a group of interconnected
devices and networking is the art of
understanding how data is sent
transmitted and received amongst these
devices you need to know various routing
protocols the tcpip and OSI models
govern networking the OSI model is
comparatively newer basically in these
models all the protocols are are grouped
into layers and work together to help
you receive data on your device sent
from a server learning networking will
help you understand the technical
aspects of data transmission which will
help you secure your data you can take
up networking certifications like
Security Plus and Cisco CCNA to gain a
strong networking Foundation another
skill that be beneficial for you is to
Master System
Administration if you think about it all
of us are CIS admins at some
level system administration is all about
configuring and maintaining computers
you must be curious to know every aspect
of your computer features and settings
and play around a bit carry out a trial
and error method and give yourself small
tasks like recovering deleted files or
monitoring old viruses on a VM explore
new techniques put them into use and
expand your
knowledge let us now move on to our
second skill knowledge of operating
systems and virtual
machines to become a cyber security Prof
professional you need to have a strong
knowledge of operating environments such
as Windows Linux and Mac OS cyber
Security Professionals largely used
Linux and it comes with several tools to
learn operating systems go ahead and set
up and use Virtual machines that as VMS
and play around with them this will help
you gain hands-on experience as a cyber
security expert you should be
comfortable working on any OS WMS allow
you to train and research in an isolated
environment and help you maximize your
skills the next point to remember is to
know Kali Linux it is the most widely
known Linux distribution for ethical
hacking and penetration
testing it comes with several hundred
tools related to penetration testing
malware analysis security research
computer forensics and so on Kali
contains several projects and you can
learn a lot another good thing about
Kali is that it is free to use so what
are you waiting for download and start
right away
remember that Linux is the backbone of
cyber security and a commonly asked
topic for cyber security interviews
especially for pentesting
roles moving on to our third skill our
third skill is network security control
it is another basic skill that every
cyber security professional should have
network security control refers to the
different measures which are employed to
enhance the security of a network it is
simple you can only Safeguard your
network if you know how it works how
routers firewalls and other devices work
a firewall is a hardware or software
that blocks incoming or outgoing traffic
from the internet to your
computer firewalls are required to
secure a network as a cyber security
expert you must be able to leverage a
firewall to filter and prevent
unauthorized traffic onto the network in
addition to that as a cyber security
expert you must know about intrusion
detection systems intrusion prevention
systems work virtual private networks
and remote
access an intrusion detection system IDs
is designed to detect unauthorized
access to a system it is used together
with a firewall and a router you should
be able to operate the IDS and recognize
any security policy violations and
malicious traffic on the
network as many of you may have used a
VPN is a connection between a VPN server
and a VPN client it is a secure tunnel
across the internet
moving on next up we have an interesting
skill any idea what that is if yes pause
and leave a comment as to what you think
the next skill will be if getting your
learning started is half the battle what
if you could do that for free visit
skillup by simply learn click on the
link in the description to know
more and before we jump into this skill
if you find this video interesting make
sure to give it a thumbs up fourth skill
on our list is coding
so you might be wondering if coding is
really required to become a cyber
security professional well it is true
that not all cyber Security
Professionals have or need coding
skills however having zero coding
knowledge May limit your opportunities
in the future knowing a couple of
programming languages will help you
identify the plan behind an attack and
defend against deadly hacking
techniques so as seen on your screens
these are the best programming languages
to learn to make your cyber security
career
worthwhile we have C and C++ the C
programming language is the backbone of
most operating systems C and C++ are
low-level programming languages that you
need to know as a cyber security
professional on the other hand python is
a highlevel programming language that is
becoming popular among cyber Security
Experts today knowing python will give
you an upper hand in your career it will
help you identify and fix
vulnerabilities JavaScript is another
high high level programming language
that adds interactivity to web pages a
good advantage of knowing JavaScript is
that you can prevent cross-side
scripting attacks from occurring as in
these attacks the attacker implants
malicious code in a web application
speaking of PHP because most of the
websites are created using PHP learning
it will help you defend against
Intruders similarly HTML is another
language cyber Security Professionals
should understand as most websites use
it and it is one of the easiest
languages to learn another programming
language that you can use is goang it is
great for cryptography you can solve
various cyber security problems with it
then we have SQL that is structured
query language attackers use this
language to damage the stored data one
such example is the SQL injection attack
hence having a good understanding of SQL
will be highly beneficial another Point
we'd like to highlight is to have
knowledge of Assembly Language this will
help you become a cyber security
engineer assembly will help you
understand how malware functions and
thereby help you defend against it in
the cyber security domain you can't just
lock into a single language and hence it
is advised that you're acquainted with a
couple of them you can also do a crash
course for these languages and learn
them hence determine the best
programming language for your cyber
security role and get familiar with the
basics moving on our fifth skill on the
list is cloud security there is a
growing demand for cyber Security
Professionals with Cloud security skills
in the coming
years companies are on the lookout for
professionals with security skills
applicable to public and hybrid Cloud
platforms such as Amazon web services
and Azure more organizations look to
Cloud infrastructure to store data and
run
applications this includes the
implementation of policies and
technologies that protect cloud-based
systems and
devices just like application
development security Cloud security also
involves building secure systems from
the start companies want professionals
who can manage the cloud security tools
to identify and prevent any Cloud
breaches people with experience and
knowledge in managing big platforms such
as Microsoft Azure AWS and the gcp are
in high demand now that we have seen the
top five cyber security skills let us go
through a set of additional skills that
can help you get into the cyber security
field remember that to become a
successful cyber security expert you
must possess a rich and diverse skill
set
so in a list of additional skills first
we have risk
analysis identifying risks even before
their arrival is a great skill cyber
Security Professionals are required to
identify manage and mitigate risks risk
management and mitigation is a skill set
that is going to be highly in demand in
the coming
years next we have information security
companies require skilled professionals
who can protect their electronic data
from unauthorized taxes here in demand
skills are authentication authorization
malware analysis and data
recovery next on our list is security
incident handling and
response as a cyber security expert you
must be prepared to handle any
forthcoming threat of violating an
organization security policy by
following an updated incident response
plan your team can proactively protect
your data and minimize the
damages in security Incident Management
you required to identify manage record
and analyze security threats in real
time a security incident can be an
active threat or a successful compromise
of data or an attempted intrusion it can
also be incidents like dos attacks
fishing APS ransomware and many more
another important pointer is that as a
security practitioner you must also
manage and analyze the security
information and event management S tools
and
services moving on we have security
audit security auditing is an internal
check that is carried out to find flaws
in the organization's information system
you must be able to conduct a review of
the organization's adherence to
regulatory guidelines security audit and
compliance knowledge are very crucial as
any Mysteria of Regulatory Compliance
could lead to Hefty penalties soon
organizations will need people who are
more familiar with the various data
privacy regulations if you are good at
paperwork you can capitalize on this
skill companies will need people who can
understand what paperwork to fight and
with security protocols to use to comply
with the
regulations finally we have laws and
regulations and often overlooked cyber
security aspect there are several cyber
security laws and regulations and if you
break these laws intentionally or not it
doesn't matter as you will still be
charged these laws Define how you can
use the internet and it also defines how
people can be protected from becoming
the victims of cyber crimes knowing
these laws and regulations and following
the best practice will make you ethical
at your job and this will in turn be
good for your organization so those were
our list of additional skills apart from
these make sure you stay updated with
new hacks and learn new tools as cyber
security is ever
evolving another important skill apart
from these technical skills is your soft
skills having a set of good soft skills
will help you bag your dream job we have
a video on the top five soft skills that
will help you grow in your career do
watch that and incorporate those skills
as well we human are highly techsavvy in
today's times with the extensive use of
the internet and modern Technologies
there is a massive challenge in
protecting all our Digital Data such as
net banking information account
credentials and medical reports to name
a few have you heard about the deadly
one to cry ransomware attack the attack
happened in May 2017 in Asia and then it
spread across the world within a day
more than 230,000 computers were
infected across 150 countries the one
cry crypto worm encrypted the data and
locked the users out of their systems
for decryption of the data the users
were asked for a ransom of $300 to $600
in Bitcoin the users who used the
unsupported version of Microsoft Windows
and those who hadn't installed the
security update of April 2017 were
targeted in this attack the one a cry
attack took a toll on every sector top
tier organizations like Itachi Nissan
and FedEx had to put their businesses on
hold as their systems were affected too
now this is what you call a Cyber attack
to prevent such attacks cyber security
is implemented we can Define cyber
security as the practice of protecting
networks programs computer systems and
their components from unauthorized
digital attacks these illegal attacks
are often referred to as hacking hacking
refers to exploiting weaknesses in a
computer network to obtain unauthorized
access to information a hacker is a
person who tries to hack into computer
systems this is a misconception that
hacking is always wrong there are
hackers who work with different motives
let's have a look at three different
types of hackers black hat hackers are
individuals who illegally hack into a
system for a monetary gain on the
contrary we have wh hat hackers who
exploit the vulnerabilities in a system
by hacking into it with permission in
order to defend the organization this
form of hacking is absolutely legal and
ethical hence they are also often
referred to as ethical hackers in
addition to these hackers we also have
the gray hat hackers as the name
suggests the color gray is a blend of
both white and black these hackers
discover vulnerabilities in a system and
report it to the system's owner which is
a good act but they do this without
seeking the owner's approval sometimes
gray hat hackers also ask for money in
return for the spotted
vulnerabilities now that you have seen
the different types of hackers let's
understand more about the hacking that
is legal and valid ethical hacking
through an interesting story Dan runs a
Trading Company he does online training
with the money his customers invest
everything was going well and Dan's
business was booming until a hacker
decided to hack the company's servers
the hacker stole the credentials of
various trading accounts he asked for a
lump some Ransom in exchange for the
stolen credentials Dan took the Hacker's
words lightly and didn't pay the hacker
as a result the hacker withdrew money
from various customers accounts and Dan
was liable to pay back the customers Dan
lost a lot of money and also the trust
of his customers after this incident Dan
gave a lot of thought as to what could
have gone wrong with the security
infrastructure in his company he wished
there was someone from his company who
could have run a test attack to see how
vulnerable systems were before the
hacker penetrated into into the network
this was when he realized he needed an
employee who thinks like a hacker and
identifies the vulnerabilities in his
Network before an outsider does to do
this job he hired an ethical hacker John
John was a skilled professional who
worked precisely like a hacker in no
time he spotted several vulnerabilities
in Dan's organization and closed all the
loopholes hiring an ethical hacker
helped Dan protect his customers from
further attacks in the future
this in turn increased the company's
productivity and guarded the company's
reputation so now you know hacking is
not always bad John in this scenario
exposed the vulnerabilities in the
existing Network and such hacking is
known as ethical hacking ethical hacking
is distributed into six different phases
let us look at these phases step by step
with respect to how JN our ethical
hacker will act before launching an
attack the first step Jon takes is to
get gather all the necessary information
about the organization's system that he
intends to attack this step is called
reconnaissance he uses tools like inmap
and hping for this purpose JN then tries
to spot the vulnerabilities if any in
the Target system using tools like inmap
and expose this is the scanning phase
now that he has located the
vulnerabilities he then tries to exploit
them this step is known as gaining
access after John makes his way through
the organization's networks he tries to
maintain his access for future attacks
by installing back doors in the Target
system the Metasploit tool helps him
with this this phase is called
maintaining access John is a brilliant
hacker hence he tries his best not to
leave any evidence of his attack this is
the fifth phase clearing tracks we now
have the last phase that is reported in
this phase John documents a summary of
his entire attack the vulnerabilities he
spotted the tools he used and the
success rate of the attack looking into
the report Dan is now able to take a
call and see how to protect his
organization from any external cyber
attacks don't you all think Jon is an
asset to any organization if you want to
become an ethical hacker like Jon then
there are a few skills that you need to
acquire first and foremost you need to
have a good knowledge of operating
environments such as Windows Linux Unix
and Macintosh you must have reasonably
good knowledge of programming languages
such as HTML PHP python SQL and
JavaScript networking is the base of
ethical hacking hence you should be good
at it ethical hackers should be well
aware of security laws so that they
don't misuse their skills finally you
must have a global certification on
ethical hacking to successfully bag a
position of an ethical hacker like John
few examples of ethical hacking
certification are certified ethical
hacker certification C CompTIA pinest
plus and licensed penetration tester
certification to name a few simply learn
provides a cyber security expert Masters
program that will equip you with all the
skills required by a cyber security
expert when it comes to web app hacking
it generally refers to the exploitation
of applications by http which can be
done by manipulating the applications
via its graphical user interface this is
done by tampering with the uniform
resource identifier also known as a URI
or tampering with the HTTP elements
directly which are not a part of the URI
the hacker can send a link via an email
or a chat and may trick the users of a
web application into executing actions
in case the attack is on an
administrator account the entire web
application can be
compromised anyone who uses a computer
connected to the internet is susceptible
to the threats that computer hackers and
online Predators pose these online Vons
typically use fishing scams spam email
or instant messages and bogus websites
to deliver dangerous malware to your
computer and compromise your computer
security computer hackers can also try
to access your computer and private
information directly if you're not
protected by a firewall they can monitor
your conversations or produce the back
end of your personal website
usually disguised with a bogus identity
Predators can lure you into revealing
sensitive personal and financial
information a web server which can be
referred to as the hardware the computer
or the software which helps to deliver
content that can be access to the
internet the primary function of a web
server is to deliver these web pages on
the request to clients using the hypex
transfer protocol or
HTTP so hackers attack the web server to
steal credential information
passwords and business information by
using different types of attacks like
dos attacks SN flooding ping flood port
scan and social engineering attacks in
the area of web security despite strong
encryption on the browser server Channel
web users still have no Assurance about
what happens at the other
end although wireless networks offer
great flexibility they have their own
security problems a hacker can sniff the
network packets without having to be in
the same building with the n network is
located as wireless networks communicate
through radio waves a hacker can easily
sniff the network from a nearby location
most attackers use Network sniffing to
find the SSID and hack a wireless
network an attacker can attack a network
from a distance and therefore it is
sometimes difficult to collect evidence
against the main
hacker social engineering is the art of
manipulating uses of a Computing system
into revealing confidential information
which can be laate dat used to gain
unauthorized access to a computer system
the term can also include activities
such as exploiting human kindness greed
and curiosity to gain access to
restricted access buildings or getting
the users to installing backd door
software knowing the tricks used by
hackers to trick users into releasing
vital login information is fundamental
in protecting computer
systems coming to our main focus for
today let us have a look at the top five
most essential ethical hacking tools to
be used in
2021 at the top of the chain lies
nmap nmap which stands for network
mapper is a free and open-source utility
for network discovery and security
auditing many systems and network
administrators also find it useful for
tasks such as Network inventory managing
service upgrade schedules and monitoring
host or service up time it is most
beneficial in the early stages of
ethical hacking where a hacker must
figure the possible entry point to a
system before running the necessary
exploits thus allowing the hackers to
leverage any insecure openings and thus
breach the
device nmap uses raw IP packets in novel
ways to determine what hosts are
available on the network what service
they are running what operating systems
are installed what type of packet
filters and firewalls are in used and
dozens other characteristics it was
designed to rapidly scan large networks
but works FS against single host as well
since every application that connects to
a network needs to do so via a port the
wrong port or a server configuration can
open a can of worms which lead to a
thorough breach of the system and
ultimately a fully hacked
device next on our list we have
Metasploit the Metasploit framework is a
very powerful tool that can be used by
cyber criminals as well as ethical
hackers to probe systematic
vulnerabilities on both networks and
servers because it's an open source
framework it can be easily customized
and used with most operating
systems with Metasploit the ethical
hacking team can use readymade or custom
code and introduce it into a network to
probe for weak spots as another flavor
of threat hunting once the flaws are
identified and documented the
information can be used to address
systemic weaknesses and prioritize
Solutions once a particular
vulnerability is ident identified and
the necessary exploit is fed into the
system there are a host of options for
the hacker depending on the
vulnerability hackers can even run root
commands from the terminal allowing
complete control over the activities of
the compromise system as well as all the
personal data stored on the
device a big advantage of Metasploit is
the ability to run full-fledged scans on
the target system which gives a detailed
picture of the security index of the
system along with the necessary exploits
that can be used to buy bypass the
antivirus softwares having a single
solution to gather almost all the
necessary points of attack is very
useful for ethical hackers and
penetration testers as denoted by its
high rank in the
list moving on we have the acuns
framework atics is an endtoend web
security scanner which offers a 360°
view of an organization security it is
an application security testing tool
that helps the company address
vulnerability across all their critical
web
assets the need to be able to test
application in depth and further than
traditional vulnerability management
tools has created a market with several
players in the application security
space actic can detect over 7,000
vulnerabilities including SQL injections
cross-site scripting misconfigurations
weak passwords exposed database and
other outof band
vulnerabilities it can scan all pages
web apps and complex web applications
running HTML 5 and JavaScript as well it
also lets you scan complex multi-level
forms and even password protected areas
of the
site actic is a dynamic application
security testing package which has
definite perks over status application
security testing Frameworks which are
also known as s scanners s tools only
work during development and only for
specific languages and have a history of
reporting a lot of false positives
whereas Dynamic testing tools also known
as D have the ability to streamline
testing from development to deployment
with minimal
issues next on our list we have air
gedon this is a multi-use bash script
used for Linux systems to hack and audit
wireless networks like our everyday
Wi-Fi router and its
counterparts along with being able to
launch denial of service attacks on
compromised networks this multipurpose
purp wi-fi hacking tool has very rich
features which support multiple methods
for wi-fi hacking including WPS hacking
modes WP attacks handshake captures evil
twin and so much
more it usually needs an external
network adapter that supports monitor
mode which is necessary to be able to
capture Wireless traffic that Traverse
the air
channels thanks to its open source
nature air Garden can be used with
multiple Community plugins and add-ons
thereby increasing its Effectiveness
against a wide variety of routers both
in the 2.4 GHz and the 5 GHz
band finally at number five we have John
the Ripper John the Ripper is an
open-source password security auditing
and the password recovery tool which is
available for many operating
systems John the Ripper jumbo supports
100 of hash and Cipher types including
for user passwords of operating systems
web apps database servers encrypted keys
and documents files some of the key
features of the tool include offering
multiple modes to speed up the password
cracking automatically deselecting the
hashing algorithm used by the passwords
and the ease of running and
configurating the tool to make it
password cracking
easier it can use dictionary attacks
along with regular brute forcing to
speed up the process of cracking the
correct password without wasting
additional resources the word list being
used in these dictionary attacks can be
used by the users and allowing for a
completely customizable
process we also have a few honorary
mentions in our list that just missed
the cut netsparker for instance is an
automated yet fully configurable web
application security scanner that
enables you to scan websites web
applications and web services the
scanning technology is designed to help
you secure web applications easily
without any fuss so you can focus on
fixing the reported
vulnerabilities the BP suit professional
is one of the most popular penetration
testing and vulnerability finder tools
and it's used for checking web
application security the term BP as it
is commonly known as a proxy based tool
which is used to evaluate the security
of web based application and to do
Hands-On testing moving away from
websites and applications yashar is a
free and open-source packet analyzer
which was launched in
2016 it is used for Network
troubleshooting analysis software and
Communications protoc called development
and education it captures Network
traffic on the local network and stores
data for offline analysis why shock
captures Network traffic from ethernet
Bluetooth wireless networks and frame
relay
connections now that we learn about the
different types of tools that can be
used when conducting an ethical hacking
audit let's learn about some potential
benefits of such campaigns and why
organizations prefer to pay for such
audits
being able to identify defects from an
attacker's perspective is game-changing
since it displays all the potential
Avenues of a possible hack one can only
prepare for the known vulnerabilities as
a defensive specialist but proactively
trying to breach a network or device can
make hackers think of techniques that no
defense contractors can account for this
kind of unpredictability goes a long way
in securing a network against malicious
actors another advant AG of hiring
ethical hackers is the ability to
preemptively fix possible weak points in
a company's Network infrastructure as
seen on many occasions a real breach
will cause loss of data and irreparable
damage to the foundation of an
organization being able to gauge such
shortcomings before they become public
and can be used exploited is a benefit
most organizations make use
of this is not to imply that such
security audits are only beneficial to
the organization paying for it when
coming across companies that provide
certain Services a reliable thirdparty
security audit goes a long way in
instilling trust and confidence over
their craft if the ethical hackers
cannot find any major vulnerabilities
that can be leveraged by hackers it just
accentuates the technical billing of the
organization and its Engineers thereby
increasing the clientele by a
substantial amount Jude is waiting at
the airport to hop on her flight back
home when she realizes that she missed
making an important Bank payment she
connects her laptop to the public Wi-Fi
at the airport and goes ahead to carry
out the bank transaction everything goes
well and Jude completes her
transaction after a couple of days she
was wiped off her feet when she learned
that her bank account was subjected to a
Cyber attack and a hefty amount was
wiped from her account after getting in
touch with the bank Authority she
learned that her account was hacked at
the airport she then realized that the
public Wi-Fi she used might have caused
her this trouble Jude wishes that had
her bank transfer escaped the Hacker's
eyes she would not have been a victim of
a Cyber
attack Bank officials advise her to use
a VPN for future transactions especially
when connecting to an open or public
network like most of us Jude had come
across the term VPN several times but
didn't know much about it and little did
she think that the repercussions of not
using a VPN would be this bad let's
understand how the hacker would have
exploited Jude's transaction in the
absence of a VPN in this process Jude's
computer first connects to the internet
service provider ISP which provides
access to the internet she sends her
details to the bank server using her IP
address Internet Protocol address or IP
address is a unique address that
recognizes a particular device be it a
laptop or a smartphone on the internet
when these details pass through the
public network the hacker who passively
watches the network traffic intercepts
it this is a passive Cyber attack where
the hacker collects judee's Bank details
without being detected more often or not
in such an attack payment information is
likely to be stolen the targeted data
here are the victim's username passwords
and other personal information such an
unsecured connection exposed judee's IP
address and Bank details to the hacker
when it passed through the public
network so would Jude have been able to
secure her transaction with the help of
a VPN well yes picture Jude's Bank
transaction to be happening in a tunnel
that is invisible to the hacker in such
a case the hacker will not be able to
spot a transaction and that is precisely
what a VPN does a virtual private
Network more often known as VPN creates
a secure tunnel between your device and
the internet for using a VPN judee's
First Step would be to install
software-based technology known as the
VPN client on her laptop or smartphone
that would let her establish a secure
connection the VPN client connects to
the Wi-Fi and then to the
ISP here the VPN client encrypts judee's
information using VPN protocols data is
encrypted to make sure it is secure next
the VPN client establishes a VPN tunnel
within the public network that connects
to the VPN server the VPN tunnel
protects jud's information from being
intercepted by the hacker judee's IP
address and actual location are changed
at the VPN server to enable a private
and secure connection finally the VPN
server connects to judee's bank server
in the last step where the encrypted
message is decrypted this way judee's
original IP address is hidden by the VPN
and the VPN tunnel protects her data
from being hacked this explains how VPN
makes your data Anonymous and secure
when it passes through the public
network and the difference between a
normal connection and a VPN connection
after after learning about this Jude was
certain that she should start using a
VPN to carry out her online transactions
in the future this is also applicable to
each one of us even if you work remotely
or connect to public Wi-Fi using a VPN
is the safest option in addition to
providing a secure encrypted data
transfer vpns are also used to disguise
your whereabouts and give you access to
Regional web content VPN servers act as
proxies on the internet this way your
act location cannot be established VPN
enables you to spoof your location and
switch to a server to another country
and thereby change your location for
example by doing so you can watch any
content on Netflix that might be
unavailable for your region meet
Jonathan he is an investigative
journalist who occasionally researches
and publishes news articles contrary to
the government's ideologies on one such
occasion he could not access a Global
News website dealing with with
uncensored information it seemed his IP
was blocked from visiting the news
website with his IP blocked Jonathan
turned to a popular proxy service that
was able to unblock the news website
thereby allowing an open internet to all
users just like how your friend gives a
proxy attendance for you a proxy server
serves as a standin user to keep the
real client private but what is a proxy
let's understand it's working by taking
a look at how Jonathan was able to
access geoblock content without much
hassle a proxy server acts as a Gateway
or intermediary server between a user
and its destination website when
Jonathan wasn't able to access the news
website he connected his system to a
global proxy server once connected the
proxy server assigns a new IP address to
Jonathan's system an IP address of a
different country where the website is
not censored following this process
whenever Jonathan visits that website
the website administrators see the new
IP address assigned via proxy server and
sees no reason to deny access to their
account once the proxy server is able to
access the website it's passed on to
Jonathan's system via the same channel
regarding accessibility to proxy servers
you must first set it up on your
computer device or network next check
the steps required for your computer or
network as each operating system has its
setup procedures in most cases however
setup intels using an automated
configuration script there are plenty of
free proxy services available on the
internet however the safety of such
proxies is rarely verified most free
proxies will provide an IP address and a
relevant port for connection purposes
reputed proxy providers like smart proxy
and WR data that run on subscription
models will most likely provide
credentials to log into when
establishing the connection this extra
step access authentication that verifies
an existing subscription on the proxy
provider server unlike free providers
that are open to all when it comes to
hiding IP addresses many people consider
a VPN to be the primary solution while
that's true up to some extent there are
a few things proxies do differently in
the case of vpns extra encryption is
also carried out to create a secure
tunnel between the user's device and a
VPN server a VPN is usually much faster
more secure thanks to multiple layers of
encryption and has little to no downtime
proxies tend to be comparatively unsafe
with the service owners having the exact
IP address of the enduser and having no
guarantees regarding downtimes and
reliability if you want to know more
about how vpns work do watch how Jude
could have protected her banking
credentials using vpns in our detailed
video linked above now let's take a
small quiz to check how much we have
learned what can a VPN connection
provide that a proxy service cannot a
new IP address B multiple layers of
encryption C access to geoblock content
D authentication credentials think about
it and leave your answers Below in the
comment section and three lucky winners
will receive Amazon gift vouchers what
about the benefits of a proxy service
though besides allowing access to
blocked content proxies can serve as an
efficient firewall system
they can also filter content from third
party websites allowing control over
internet usage in many cases browsing
speeds are stabilized compared to
vanilla Internet thanks to proper
optimization of the Bas proxy server the
element of privacy proxy provides is
highly lucrative to people looking to
hide their actual IP address from as
many crying eyes as possible one can
easily argue the benefits of using VPN
over proxies for added security measures
however a few basic tasks don't warrant
maximum privacy for the user side as in
other cases for example many consumers
worldwide find proxy Services more
convenient since all major operating
systems starting from Windows to Android
allow proxy configuration without the
hassle of installing new applications as
is in the case of a VPN in addition
there are services online that function
as web proxies allowing users to access
block content without any setup from
their end
they can enter the target URL and the
web proxy will route data from its
physical server this level of freedom is
hard to come by in the case of vpns
making proxies an ideal solution for
casual browsing with the next generation
of Internet exchanges focused on maximum
privacy and security a variety of ways
have been enforced to maintain them as
such censorship has been shifted from
the streets to the digital domain it
forces the standard citizen to derive
alternative ways to maintain anonymity
major weapon in this battle for privacy
and security is the T browser an
independent browser meant to browse the
internet while reeling information
through the Tor Network it serves as a
meaningful alternative to the standard
internet browsing habits to better
understand the purpose of this browser
and such we must learn about the work of
the T Network featuring its own routing
protocol the to browser is an easy way
to maintain anonymity while browsing
without emptying one's wallet let's take
a look at the topics to be covered today
we start at the explanation of what is
the T Network and its significance in
the working of the to
browser we take a look at the onion
routing protocol and how it transmits
the data from the client devices to the
Tor directories in order to circumvent
government
sensorship moving on we learn a few
features of the to browser and the
distinct advantages the to network
provides next we learn the difference
between using a VPN and a tour to
anonymize internet usage and finally we
have a live demonstration of the T
browser anonymization features in
action let's move on to learning about
the T
Network T short for the onion router
it's an open source privacy Network that
permits users to browse the web
anonymously the T was initially
developed and solely used by the US Navy
to protect sensitive government
Communications before the network was
made publicly available the digital era
has disrupted the traditional way of
doing things in every sector of the
economy the rapid rise in development
and innovation of digital products has
given way to frequent data breaches and
cyber thefts in response consumers are
increasingly opting for products that
offer data privacy and cyber security T
is one such underground Network that was
implemented for the purpose of
protecting users identities the T
network is one example of the many
emerging technologies that attempt to
fill a data privacy void in a digital
space plagued by cyber security
concerns the to network intercepts the
traffic from your browser and bounces a
user's request of a random number of
other user IP addresses then the data is
passed to the user request Final
Destination these random users are
volunteer devices which are called as
nodes or relays the T Network disguises
your identity by encrypting the traffic
and moving it across different to relays
within the network the T Network uses an
onion routing techn for transmitting
data hence the original name of onion
router to operate within the Tor Network
a user has to install the T browser any
address or information requested using
the browser is transmitted through the T
Network it has its own feature set which
we will be going over later in this
video as we discussed already the data
passing through the to network must
follow a unique protocol known as The
Onion routing protocol let us learn more
about its unique characteristics
in our normal Network usage the data is
transmitted directly the sender has data
packets to transmit which is done
directly over a line of communication
with either a receiving party or a
server of some kind however since the
data can easily be captured while being
transmitted the security of this
exchange is not very reliable moreover
it becomes very easy to trace the origin
of such requests on many occasions
websites with questionable and
controversial content are blocked from
the ISP this is possible since the ISP
is able to detect and spy on user
information passing through the network
apart from isps there is a steady chance
of your private information being
intercepted by hackers unfortunately
easy detection of the source and
contents of a web request make entire
network extremely vulnerable for people
who seek anonymity over the
Internet however in the onion routing
protocol things take a longer route we
have a sender with the to browser
installed on the client system
the network sends the information to
node one's IP address which encrypts the
information and passes it on to node 2's
address which performs another
encryption and passes it on to node 3
address this is the last address which
is also known as the exit node this last
node decrypts the encrypted data and
finally relays the request to the Final
Destination which can be another device
or a server end this final address
thinks the request came from the exit
node and grants access to it the
encryption process across multiple
computers repeats itself from the exit
node to the original user the to network
obfuscates user IP addresses from
unwanted surveillance by keeping the
users's request untraceable with
multiple servers touching the data it
makes the tracking very difficult for
both isps and malicious
attackers now that we understand the way
T Works let us learn more about the T
browser the to browser was developed by
a nonprofit organization as a part part
of the T project in 2008 and its first
public release was announced the to
browser is a browser forked from the
popular Firefox that anonymizes your web
traffic using the to network if you're
investigating a competitor researching
an opposing litigant in a legal dispute
or just think it's creepy for your ISP
or the government to know what websites
you visit the to browser might be the
right
solution before the to browser were
developed using that Network to maintain
anonymity was a huge task for every
everyday consumers starting from the
setup to the usage the entire process
demanded a lot of knowledge and practice
the to browser manage to make it easy
for users to Traverse the relay servers
inour and guarantee the privacy of the
data
exchange a major feature of the tour
browser is the ability to delete all
browser history cookies and tracking
data the moment it is closed every new
launch of the browser opens an empty
slate having a usage habits from being
tracked and singled out a major feature
that is the highlight of the to network
is the availability of onion links only
a small portion of the worldwide web is
available to the general public we have
the Deep Web that contains links that
are not allowed to be indexed by
standard search engines like Google and
Bing the dark web is a further subset of
the Deep Web which contains onion links
to browser gives you access to these
onion websites which are only available
within the to network onion is a special
ed top level domain which designates an
anonymous onion service which is also
known as a hidden service similar to The
Links of the Deep Web these onion links
provide services like online shopping
cryptocurrency and many other products
not available in the consumer Internet
space often being considered as a Haven
for illegal activities and sales onion
links provide both information and
Assets in a private manner without the
risk of spying by
authorities browsing the web over tour
is slower than the clear net due to the
multiple layers of encryption some web
services also block to users to browser
is also illegal in authoritarian regimes
that want to prevent citizens from
Reading publishing and communicating
anonymously journalists and dissidents
around the world have embraced t as a
Cornerstone of democracy and researchers
are hard at work at improving towards
anonymity
properties let us take a look at some of
the advantages of using the T browser of
standard web
browsers the highlight of using the T
browser is to maintain anonymity over
the Internet the cause for such requests
can differ from person to person but all
of these concern are answered by the to
network doubting the information via
multiple nodes and relay servers make it
entirely difficult for the ISP to keep a
track of usage
data the entire to project is designed
to be completely free and open source
allowing the code for the browser to be
inspected and audited by Third parties
helps in the early detection of faulty
configurations and critical bugs it is
present for multiple operating system
starting from laptops to mobile
devices a number of websites are blocked
by governments for a variety of reasons
journalists under authoritarian regimes
have difficulty in getting the word out
regarding the situation since the onion
routing protocol transfers data between
multiple servers of random countries the
domains being blocked become available
when used via T usage of these
encryption messaging platforms is easily
enforced using the T browser which which
otherwise would have been a difficult
task under oppressive
circumstances many people believe that a
VPN offers the same benefits as the top
browser let's put both of them to the
test and see the differences between
them coming to the first point of
difference to is completely free and
open source all of the code for the
browser and the network can be audited
and has been cleared for security
concerns when it comes to VPN there are
many different brands which have open
source clients but the same cannot be
said for their counterparts some have
partly open source while some have
completely locked up their code so that
they cannot be stollen
further moving on T has multiple relay
points in his data transfer protocol
between the server and the receiver
there are three different IP nodes that
number can increase but it'll always be
more than two once the data is passed
from the cender it goes through all of
those relay points while in the case of
a VPN the connection is made from the
client device to the VPN server and then
to the requested destination there is no
other IP node that comes into work here
thereby making the connection a one to
one between the client and a
VPN as a next Point since store handles
multiple layers of encryption and the
data passes through multiple systems
along the way the performance is slow
compared to a VPN where the performance
is relatively fast due to the less
number of nodes the data passes
through similarly the multi-layer
encryption of T is consistent if you use
T browser every single request passes
through the same layer of encryption and
follows the same routing protocol in the
case of a VPN different companies offer
different levels of encryption some have
multihop some prefer a single onetoone
connection and these kind of differences
make the choice much more
variable finally the noes and relays
being used in the Tor Network are
volunteer there is no company holding
over them so jurisdiction becomes
relatively straightforward for in the
case of vpns many such vpns are hosted
by adware companies or are being
monitored by Central governments to note
the usage
information now that we have a better
understanding of the T browser and its
routing let us take a look at how the T
browser can anonymize and protect our
internet
usage on opening of the tour browser for
the first time this is the page that
you're going to be welcomed with you
have the option of connecting to the
Todd Network before we start our
browsing so let's press
connect and we can see that it is
connected coming to the
anonymization let's check my current
location on Google
Chrome currently is showing as Navi
Mumbai in
Maharashtra if you check the same link
on the T browser we should get a
different
address now every link that we open in
the tour browser will be little delayed
and the speed will be hampered because
of the multiple layers of encryption
like we discussed now as you can
see it's showing a German IP and the
state of
Bavaria this is how the anonymization
works there is no VPN configured there
is no proxy attached it's straight up
the out of the box settings that come
inbuilt with the T browser similarly we
have an option of cleaning up the data
let's say if you want to refresh your
location and you want to use a different
ID for the next browsing session if you
just restart it once and we can have to
check it
again we should be seeing a different
country this
time as you can see we have Netherlands
right now so this is how you can keep
refreshing your address you can keep
refreshing your host location so that
you cannot be tracked when in browsing
the internet like we discussed we have
some onion links that can only be used
on the T
Network as you can see these kind of
links do not open in the Google Chrome
browser but once we copy these over to
the T
browser as you can see we have opened
the hidden wiki which is available only
on the T Network this is kind of an
alternative Wikipedia website where we
can find articles to read and more
information to learn similarly we have
another onion link over
here which is once again available only
for the toall
browser now these kind of delays are
expected but they are a valid compromise
because they maintain the anonymity that
many people desire similarly we have
found a hidden wallet which is a
cryptocurrency wallet which is
specifically for dark web members
this operates over the Tor Network and
this is used by mostly journalists and
people who want to anonymize their
internet transactions when it comes to
dealing
money all of the transactions that occur
over the T Network are almost impossible
to track therefore these kind of
cryptocurrency wallets are very big on
the Deep Web this is just one example
while having multiple different wallets
for every single cryptocurrency
available imagine our houses without a
fence or boundary wall
this would make our properly easy
accessible to trespassers and robbers
and place our homes at Great risk right
hence fencing our property helps
safeguarded and keeps trespassers at Bay
similarly imagine our computers and
networks without protection this would
increase the probability of hackers
infiltrating our networks to overcome
this challenge just like how boundary
walls protect our houses a virtual wall
helps Safeguard and secure our devices
from Intruders and such a wall is known
as a firewall firewalls are security
devices that filter the incoming and
outgoing traffic within a private
Network for example if you were to visit
your friend who lives in a gated
community you would First Take
permission from the security guard the
security guard would check with your
friend if you should be allowed entry or
not if all is well your access is
granted on the other hand the security
guard would not Grant permission to a
trespasser looking to enter the same
premises here the entry access depends
solely on your friend the resident's
discretion the role of the security
guard in this case is similar to that of
a firewall the firewall works like a
gatekeeper at your computer's entry
point which only welcomes incoming
traffic that it has been configured to
accept firewalls filter the network
traffic within your network and analyzes
which traffic should be allowed or
restricted based on a set of rules in
order to spot and prevent cyber attacks
your computer communicates with the
internet in the form of network packets
that hold details like the source
address destination address and
information these Network packets enter
your computer through ports the firewall
works on a set of rules based on the
details of these Network packets like
their Source address a destination
address content and port numbers only
trusted traffic sources or IP addresses
are allowed to enter your network when
you connect your computer to the
internet there is a high chance of
hackers infiltrating your your network
this is when a firewall comes to your
Rescue by acting as a barrier between
your computer and the internet the
firewall rejects the malicious data
packet and thus protects your network
from hackers on the other hand traffic
from trusted websites is allowed access
to your network this way the firewall
carries out quick assessments to detect
malware and other suspicious activities
thereby protecting your network from
being susceptible to a Cyber attack
firewalls can either be Hardware or
software software firewalls are programs
installed on each computer this is also
called a host firewall meanwhile
Hardware firewalls are equipments that
are established between the Gateway and
your network linky routers are a good
example of a hardware firewall besides
this there are other types of firewalls
designed based on their traffic
filtering methods structure and
functionality the firewall that compares
each outgoing and incoming Network
packet to a set of established rules
such as the allowed IP addresses IP
protocols port number and other aspects
of the packet is known as a packet
filtering firewall if the incoming
Network traffic is not for the
predefined rules that traffic is blocked
a variant of the packet filtering
firewall is the stateful inspection
firewall these types of firewalls not
only examine each Network packet but
also checks whether or not that Network
packet is part of an established network
connection such firewalls are also
referred to as Dynamic packet filtering
firewalls our next typee of firewall is
called a proxy firewall this draws close
comparison to how you give proxy
attendance for a friend like how you
take the authority to represent your
friend the proxy firewall pretends to be
you and interacts with the internet they
come between you and the internet and
thereby prevents direct connections this
protects your device's identity and
keeps the network safe from potential
attacks only if the incoming data packet
contents are protected the proxy
firewall transfers it to you they're
also known as application Level Gateway
the firewall can spot malicious actions
and block your computer from receiving
data packets from harmful sources in
addition to preventing cyber attacks
firewalls are also used in educational
institutions and offices to restrict
users access to certain websites or
applications it is used to avoid access
to unauthorized content it's the year
2015 and Richard has just finished
playing games on his computer
after a long gaming session Richard
tries to shut it down but finds some
random text file on the desktop that
says Ransom note the text file mentioned
how a hacking group had encrypted
Richard's game files in private
documents and he had to pay a ransom of
$500 worth of bitcoin in a specified
Bitcoin address Richard quickly checked
his files only to see them being
encrypted and unreadable this is the
story of how the Tesla Crypt ransomware
spread in 2015 which which affected
thousands of Gamers before releasing the
master key used for encrypting the files
so what is ransomware for Richard to be
targeted by such an attack he must have
installed applications from untrusted
sources or clicked an unverified link
both of them can function as gateways
for a ransomware breach ransomware is a
type of malware that encrypts personal
information and documents while
demanding a ransom amount to decrypt
them this Ransom payment is mainly done
using cryptocurrency to ensure anonymity
but can also employ other routes once
the files are encrypted or locked behind
a password a text files available to the
victim explaining how to make the ransom
payment and unlock the files for it just
like Richard found the ransom node text
file on his desktop even after the money
has been paid there's no guarantee that
the hackers will send the decryption key
or unlock the files but in certain
sensitive situations victims make the
payment hoping for the best
having never been introduced to
ransomware attacks before this gave
Richard an opportunity to learn more
about this and he began his research on
the topic the spread of ransomware
mostly starts with fishing attacks to
know more about fishing attacks click
the link in the button above users tend
to click on unknown links received via
emails and chat applications promising
rewards of some nature once clicked the
ransomware files installed on the system
that encrypts all the files or blocks
access to computer functions they can
also be spread via malware transmitted
via untrusted application installation
or even a compromised wireless network
another way to breach a system with
ransomware is by using the remote
desktop protocol or RDP access a
computer can be accessed remotely using
this protocol allowing a hacker to
install malicious software on the system
with the owner unaware of these
developments coming to the different
types of ransomware first we have Locker
ransomware Ware which is a type of
malware that blocks standard computer
functions from being accessed until the
payment to the hackers is complete it
shows a log screen that doesn't allow
the victim to use the computer for even
basic purposes another type is crypto
ransomware which encrypts the local
files and documents in the computers
once the files are encrypted finding the
decryption key is impossible unless the
ransomware variant is old and the keys
are already available on the internet
scareware is fake software that claims
to have detected a virus or other issue
on your computer and directs you to pay
to resolve the problem some types of
scareware lock the computer While others
simply flood the screen with popup
alerts without actually damaging files
to prevent getting affected by
ransomware Richard could have followed a
few steps to further enhance his
security one must always have backups of
their data cloud storage for backup is
easy but a physical backup in a hard
drive is always recommended keeping the
system updated with the latest security
patches is always a good idea apart from
system updates one must always have
reputed antivirus software installed
many antivirus software like kasperski
and Bit Defender have anti-ransomware
features that periodically check for
encryption of private documents when
browsing the internet a user must always
check for the lock symbol on the address
bar which signifies the presence of
https protocol for additional security
if a system is infected with ransomware
already there's a website Noor ransom.
org it has a collection of decryption
tools for most well-known ransomware
packages it can also help decrypt
specific encrypted files if the list of
anti-ransomware tools didn't help the
victim malware is a malicious software
that is programmed to cause damage to a
computer system Network and Hardware
devices many malicious programs like
prion viruses bombs and Bots which cause
damage to the system are known as
malware most of the malware programs are
designed to steal information from the
targeted user or to steal money from the
Target by stealing sensitive
data let's take a look at the
introduction for two different types of
malware virus and
Trojan firstly let's take a look what
exactly is a virus
program a computer virus is a type of
malicious program that on execution
replicates itself they get attached to
different files and programs which are
termed as host programs by inserting
their code if the attachment succeeds
the targeted program is termed as
infected with a computer virus now let's
take a look at the Trojan hor Trojan
Horse program is a program that
disguises itself as a legitimate program
but harms the system on installation
they hide within the attachments and
emails then transfer from one system to
another
they create back doors into our system
to allow the cyper criminal to steal our
information let's take a look how they
function after getting installed into
our
system firstly we have virus programs
the computer virus must contain two
parts to infect the system first is a
search routine which locates new files
and data that is to be infected by the
virus program and the second part is
known as the copy routine which is
necessary for the program to copy itself
into the targeted file which is located
by the search routine now let's take a
look at the troan hor
functioning for Trojan horses entryway
into our system is through emails that
may look legitimate but may have unknown
attachments and when such files are
downloaded into the device the troen
program gets installed and infects the
system they also infect the system on
the execution of infected application or
the executable file and attacks the
system now that we understand what virus
and prions are let's understand
different types of virus and
rions let's take a look at different
types of viruses the first one is known
as the boot sector virus this type of
virus damages the booting section of the
system by infecting the master bot
record which is also known as MBR this
damages the boot sector section by
targeting the hard disk of the system
system then we have the macro virus
macro virus is a type of virus that gets
embedded into the document related data
and is executed when the file is open
they also are designed to replicate
themselves and infect the system on a
larger scale and lastly we have the
direct action
virus this type of virus gets attached
to executable files which on execution
activates the virus program and infects
the system once the infection of the
file is completed they exit the system
which is also the reason it is known as
a non-resident virus let's take a look
at different types of
troan the first type of troan is the
back door troan they are designed to
create a back door in the system on
execution of an infected program they
provide remote access of our system to
the hacker this way the Cyber criminal
can steal our system data and may use it
for illegal activities next we have cric
sour Rion they enter the system by
clicking the random popups which we come
across on the internet they attempt the
user to give their personal details for
different transactions or
schemes which may provide remote access
of a system to the Cyber
criminal and the last troan type is
Ransom troan this type of troan program
after entering the system blocks the
user from accessing its own system and
also affects the system
functioning the Cyber criminal Demands a
ransom from the targeted user for the
removal of the troan program from the
device now that we understand some
details regarding viruses and troan
let's solve a
question the question is Jake was denied
access to his system and he wasn't able
to control the data and information in a
system now the actual question is what
could be the reason behind this system's
problem option a macrovirus option b
Ransom troen option C back door Rion
give your answers in the comment
section now let's understand how to
detect the activity of viruses and prion
in our
system to detect virus or Troon activity
in our system we can refer to the
following points for viruses we have
slowing down of the system and frequent
application freeze shows that the
infection of the virus is present in the
system then we have the viruses can also
steal sensitive data including passwords
Account Details which may lead to
unexpected log out from the accounts or
Corruption of the sensitive data and
lastly we have frequent system crashes
due to virus infection which damages the
operating system for Trojan we have
frequent system crashes and system also
faces slow reaction time
then we have there are more random
popups from the system which may
indicate troan activity and lastly we
have modification in the system
application and change of the desktop
appearance can be also due to the
infection of a troan
program next let's take a look at a
famous Cyber attack for virus and a
trojen
hor for virus we have the maom virus
which was identified in the year 2004
which affected over 50 million systems
by creating a network of sending spam
emails which was to gain back to access
into our
systems next for the troan horse we have
the emot troan program which is a
specifically designed for financial
theft and for stealing Bank related
information next we have few points for
how to prevent virus entry or troan
attack for a
system the most basic way of virus
protection is to using antivirus and do
regular viruses scan this will prevent
virus entry in the system and also
having more than one antivirus provides
birge better
protection then avoid visiting
uncertified websites can also prevent
virus entry into our
system then we have using regular driver
updates and system updates to prevent
virus entry for troan we have using
certified softwares from legal sites to
prevent any troan activity in our
system and also avoid clicking random
popups that we often see on the internet
and lastly using antivirus and Fireballs
for protection against troan horses is a
good
habit now that we have reached the end
of the video Let's Take a look what we
learned for the first part we saw the
main objective of the virus is to harm
the data and information in a system
whereas for the troan we have stealing
of the data files and information effect
of viruses is more drastic in comparison
to the Trojan
horses then we have viruses which are
non- remote programs whereas troen
horses are remote accessed and lastly
viruses have the ability to replicate
itself to harm multiple files whereas
Trojan does not have the replication
ability so so let's begin with what is
SQL
injection as the name suggest SQL
injection vulnerability allows an
attacker to inject malicious input into
a SQL statement so SQL stands for
structured query language which is a
language used by an application to
interact with the database now normally
this attack is targeted towards a
database to extract uh the data that is
stored within however the vulnerability
does not lie in the database itself the
vulnerability will always lie in the
application it is the developers
prerogative of how to develop the
application how to configure it to
prevent SQL injection queries from
happening a database is created to
answer questions and if a question is
asked it is supposed to answer it
database needs to be configured for some
amount of security but the vulnerability
the flaw here for SQL injection will
always lie in the application itself it
is how the application interacts with
the database that needs to be modified
that needs to be maintained by the
developer rather than just configuring
the database itself so the attacker at
this point in time when the send a query
to the application will form a malformed
query by injecting a particular command
or an operator that is recognized by the
SQL language and if that operator is
passed through the application to the
database then the database basically
gets cracked or does a data dump because
of that unwanted character coming in so
this character needs to be filtered at
the application Level itself now let's
look at a quick demo so what we have
done here is I have this virtual machine
called oasp broken web applications
virtual machine version 1.2 I'm going to
power this
on till this power is on I'm going to
show you where we can download this uh
utility from so you can just look for o
broken web application project download
you'll find it on sourceforge.net click
on the
link you can download the broken web
application project from here this is a
1.9gb download and you can have a zip
machine directly for VMware or Oracle
virtual box now this is an application
that has been developed by oasp which
stands for open web application security
project which is a not for-profit
organization and uh periodically uh
releases the most top 10 risks that an
application uh will face for that
particular
year so they have given a web
application uh with inbuilt
vulnerabilities for professionals like
us to practice upon to develop our our
skills upon because doing this in the
real world is illegal I cannot go onto a
website to demonstrate how a SQL
injection attack Works uh neither should
you try your hands on it till you become
very well rehearsed with it so till to
upgrade your skills to upskill yourself
please download this machine hosted in a
VMV workstation or Oracle virtual box
and you can uh then try your skills on
it right so uh just going back to the
browser here if I open up uh a new tab
you'll see that this machine has booted
up and has an IP address called 7113 to
so if I just go on to that IP address
address and I type in 192
132 and you'll see the oasp broken web
application project and there are a lot
of training applications realistic
intentionally vulnerable applications
old versions of real applications and so
on so forth so there is a lot of
applications in built over here that you
can try your skills upon we are going to
try to use the ovas mutil day over here
uh this gives you the uh oos top 10
risks for 2010 2013 2017 is the latest
one so far uh but the difference between
2013 and 2017 is that some of these have
changed but not all of them uh the order
has changed a little bit but you can see
that SQL injection is on the top A1
amongst the injection attacks right and
you can see there are multiple types
that have been given here the SQL
injection for extracting data or SQL
injection for bypass authentication or
insert your injection uh ATT blind SQL
injection and then there is a tool
called SQL map which is available freely
on your Linux machines Ki Linux or parro
Linux whichever you want to use uh for
your practice targets and so on so forth
so if I just take you here for bypass
authentication and this is a regular
login page that an application may have
right you look at a username you look at
password you type that in and you log in
so let's say I don't know a password
here I'm just going to type in the
username test password is pssw Rd I try
to log in and it shows me that the
account does not exist so the
authentication mechanism does work I did
try type in a username and password it
wasn't recognized so the account does
not exist now let's try to type in a SQL
query here I'm going to just give it a
single quote which is an operator that
is recognized by the SQL language which
when the database tries to execute uh
will cause the data
to uh dump some data or to bypass
authentication in this case and I'm
going to give it a condition single
quote r 1 equal 1 space hyphen hyphen
space and I'm going to click on login
now right now I'm not logged in at all
and we tried our username and password
and we weren't able to log in so now if
I log in you will see that it give me a
status update saying the user has been
authenticated and I'm logged in as admin
got root so that is what these SQL
queries can achieve I'm going to log out
right now and uh we're going to look at
the basics of SQL injection so looking
at that small demo looking now let's
look at what types of seel injections
are available so the first is inband SQL
injection the there are two subtypes
within inband error based injection
attack and a union based injection
attack the second type is blind SQL
injection attack where there's a Boolean
based and a Time based attack and the
third one is outof bound SQL injection
attack now what is inband SQL injection
attack inband is where we either
attempting the error based or the union
based what is error based uh we send a
query to the database we craft a query
to the database and uh it generates an
error me message and it dumps the error
message right in front of us on the
screen that makes us realize that there
is a flow law and there there is some
information that is dumped on the screen
which we can then further utilize to
craft our further queries as we go ahead
whereas Union base is the it is where we
combine multiple statements at the same
time so if you look at the URL earlier
in the URL uh you would see a large
structure in that URL uh we can try to
add more two or more statements within
the URL itself to combine them and then
confuse the database into executing both
the statements together and giving a
data dump at the same time right so what
would a error waste uh SQL injection
look like if I go back to the same
database uh which is here right and if
you remember the username we gave it uh
single quote r 1 equals 1 space hyphen
hyphen space we gave it the condition
right so basically what it did was this
a single code is an operator that goes
to the database selects the default uh
table uh in the user tables in this
database column and then Compares it to
the condition that is given so the
condition that we gave was 1 equals 1
which is always true so what it did was
it selected the default uh user table
that was available in the database and
instead of comparing it to a password it
compared it to the condition so if I
give it 1 equals 2 where the condition
is false and if I log in you will see
that the account doesn't exist comes
back again because the condition was
false and instead of comparing the user
account to the password it basically uh
compared the user account to the
condition so if I give it a single quote
or 1 equals 1 hyphen space uh and log in
you can see that this is a correct
condition and thus we are able to log in
now before we even go to that extent if
I just forget the condition over here
and I just give it a single code the
operator and I send this operator to the
database and I click on login you will
see that it generates an error which is
right on top and it tells us the line
the uh file where the error happened and
you can see it happened in the MySQL
handler. PHP file right and then it give
us the message you have an error in your
SQL syntax check the manual that
corresponds to your MySQL server version
for the right syntax to use now why
would a hacker want to do this in the
first place because there are different
types of databases so there is a MySQL
Ms SQL or Microsoft SQL Oracle SQL IBM
db2 all of these are variations of the
SQL database uh they use the SQL
language however every database has its
own Command right they they have their
own syntax they have their own uh
specific commands that are utilized for
the database so in this scenario the
hacker wants to identify what database
is being currently utilized so they can
craft those particular queries so now
with this injection with just me sending
the quote and the error getting
generated I now come to know that we are
using a MySQL server and the version of
that server is 5.1.7 3 and uh the rest
of the information about uh where the
handlers are located and so on so forth
right this gives the information to the
hacker of how they want to proceed next
what kind of queries they want to create
what kind of syntax they want to utilize
so error BAS attack is where you
generate these kind of Errors uh and you
get this information the union base is
where you craft your queries within the
URL or you can try to combine multiple
statements within the input fields and
try to generate a response from that
then we come to Boolean based SQL
injection uh sends a SQL query to the
database which forces the application to
return a different result depending on
whether the query returns a true or a
false result so basically if the input
is false the input both the inputs are
false the output would be false uh
there's one input that is false the
other input that is true input B the
output would be true and so on so forth
right so depending on the result from
the inputs the attack will come to know
which input is true with this he can
then access the database of the website
so you're trying to figure out by
sending out multiple inputs uh and then
analyzing the output to see what exactly
uh which command exactly work what was
the resultant output of that command
thus from this kind of an information
the hacker can infer their next step
forward then you have time based SQL
injections uh now there are times when a
database administrator an application
administrator has done some security
configuration and does have disabled
verbos error messages now what is a
verbos error message the error message
that we saw right here is a verbos error
message that means means that the
message gives out details the message
gives out details about what the
database is the version and whatnot so
if they have sanitized these
errors and you no longer can generate
these errors and thus you cannot figure
out what database is then what do you do
right for example if I just take you to
Simply
learn and
take you to a URL that is supposedly not
accessible you can see that it gives a
generic error oops like it looks like
you have crash landed on Mars it doesn't
give you a verbose error that we saw
here so this gives us a detail error of
what went wrong where it gives us the
database the version of the database and
uh where the query went wrong and etc
etc etc whereas on this s where there's
some there's a lot of security that goes
in here so you can see that it doesn't
generate a error it just get a generic
page in front of you so in that case
what does a hacker do so the hacker then
injects a Time based uh query in the URL
which allows us to verify whether the
command is being executed or not so uh
we put in a time
weit let's say 10 seconds of time weit
so if we the moment we inject the query
if the query times for 10 seconds and
then gets executed that means that the
SQL injection is possible however if we
inject the query and uh it just gets
executed without the delay that means
that the time uh injection attack would
not be uh possible on that particular
site out of bound is not a very common
attack it depends on the features being
enabled on the database management
system that is being used by the web
application so this can be a somewhat of
a misconfiguration error uh by the
database administrator where you have
enabled functions and not sanitized them
so you have not done in access controls
properly you have not given account
control so queries should never be
executed at an administrative level they
should always be uh executed at a user
level with minimum privileges that are
required for that query to be executed
now if you're allowing these kind of
functions to be uh to be enabled at the
dbms and there is an administrative
account that can have access to them at
that point in time an outof bound
injection attack is possible so let's
look at how a website works right uh how
SQL works on a website now the website
is constructed of HTML hypertext markup
language uh which would include
javascripting for function functionality
cascading stylesheets for the mapping of
the website right and then reactjs and
whatnot for for the functionality now
when we send a query to the website it
is normally using the HTTP protocol or
https protocol when the query reaches
the application the application would
then go ahead and generate the SQL query
uh at the client side you'll have uh all
these scripting languages coming in uh
on the front end uh that we can utilize
to craft queries and then send them
across at the server side you'll have uh
databases like Oracle MySQL Ms SQL and
so and so forth that will then execute
those queries right so just to give you
an example if I use a tool called
Postman what we generally do uh when we
craft a query is we send out a uh get
request to the website and then we
receive a response from the site uh with
the HTML code and everything so this is
a tool that is utilized by software
testers to test the responses that
you're going to get from various
websites so on the left hand side you
can see I've uh used it on quite a bit
uh here we have a example for gmail.com
so let's continue with that so this is a
get request being sent to Gmail the
moment I send it it's going to create an
HTTP request and send it across the
response that I get is this this is the
HTML code for
gmail.com right these are the cookies
uh these are the headers uh that include
information so you can see this is a
text HTML character set utilized is
utf8 and the configuration uh that has
been done with the application right so
this is where uh everything comes in
this is the cookie that has been sent
with that particular uh request that I
had sent out now if you Analyze This
query right so when we went onto this
application and I typed in that single
quote and we generated this error right
uh you can see that the application
converted this into a SQL query so the
query was select username from accounts
where the username in quote single
quotes and we use the quote right the
single quote right there so uh that's
where we use that operator and that's
where the exception error occurred so
these are the kind of queries that are
structured by the application and then
taken on to the database for execution
when we type in uh it is a http get
request with the username and password
within that query uh that is sent to the
application the application converts it
into a SQL query sends it to the
database and the database responds with
the appropriate response so how do we
prevent SQL injection in the first place
use prepared statements and
parameterized queries uh these
statements make sure that the parameters
passed into SQL statements are treated
in a safe manner so for example we saw
that the single code was an operator
this shouldn't be allowed to be utilized
in the first place right so here what we
are doing here is a secure way of
running a SQL query in the jdbc using a
parameterized statement Define which
user we want to find so there's a string
the email comes in connection to the
database we are going to figure out how
the connection is going to be passed how
it is going to be created construct the
SQL statement we want to run specifying
the parameter right so we Define how is
it going to be uh created what is going
to be created what can be passed to the
database and should not be passed to the
database so that is one way of utilizing
prepared statements and parameterized
queries then we have object relational
mapping most development uh teams prefer
to use OB object relational mapping
Frameworks to the translation of SQL
results set into code objects more
seamless so this is an example of object
relational mapping uh where we map
certain objects and allow that to be
executed and then escaping inputs it a
simple way to protect against most SQL
injection attacks many languages have
standard functions to achieve this right
so you need to be very careful while
using Escape characters in your code
base when a SQL statement is constructed
not all injection attacks rely on abuse
of code characters so you need to know
what characters are being utilized uh in
the configuration that you have created
in the structure that you have created
in the code that you have created uh
which characters are being recognized as
as operators you need to sanitize those
operators and you need to uh basically
ensure that these operators cannot be
accepted as user input if they are they
feed out by the application and they
never reach the database other methods
of uh preventing SQL injection are uh
password hashing so that passwords
cannot be bypassed the passwords cannot
be recovered passwords cannot be cracked
uh third party authentication you use o
or uh some other service for a single
sign on mechanism does uh you rely on a
third party to maintain the security of
authentication and uh what kind of
parameters are passed for example uh
using LinkedIn logins or Facebook logins
right uh for the Layman you normally go
on to Facebook and you allow if you're
using a game right if you're start
playing a game you're allowed to log
into the game using your Facebook
credentials or your Google credentials
now that is not just for ease of use but
the game user the developer has
outsourced the authentication mechanisms
to third party such as Facebook or
Google because they understand that that
authentication mechanism is as safe as
can be Facebook and Google are wealthy
organizations uh hire a lot of Security
Experts and the development for their
authentication mechanisms is topnotch
small organization cannot spend that
kind of money on security itself right
so you use a third party authentic ation
mechanism to ensure that these kind of
attacks may not happen then web
application firewalls uh having a web
application firewall and configuring it
properly uh for SQL injection attacks is
one of the shhot method of uh mitigating
or minimizing the uh threat in the first
place so at this point in time you have
realized that the application has some
vulnerabilities for SQL injection and
instead of recoding or restructuring the
application uh you want to take the
easier way out or the cheaper way out so
what you do is you uh you install a web
application firewall and you configure
the web application firewall to identify
malicious queries and stop them uh at
the firewall level itself so they never
reach the application and thus the
vulnerabilities on the application don't
get
executed buy better software and keep on
updating the software so it's not
necessary that once you have a software
you install it it's going to be safe for
Life new world ities are discovered
every day every hour and it may so
happen what is secure today may be
completely insecure tomorrow or the day
after right so you need to keep on
upgrading the software if there are no
upgrades available and the viability
still exist you might want to migrate to
a better software and does uh ensure
that you don't get hacked right always
update and use patches organizations
keep on sending out updates and patches
as and when they are released you need
to install them to uh enhance your
security postures and then continuously
monitor SQL statements and databases use
protocol monitors uh use different
softwares use the firewalls to keep on
monitoring what kind of queries you uh
getting and based on those queries you
want to ensure the inputs and the
queries that are creating U are not
detrimental to the health of the
software that you have Jane is relaxing
at home when she receives an email from
a bank that asks her to update her
credit card pen in the next 24 hours as
a security measure judging the severity
of the message Jane follows the link
provided in the email on delivering her
current credit card pin and the
supposedly updated one the website
became unresponsive which prompted her
to try sometime later however after a
couple of hours she noticed a
significant purchase from a random
website on that same credit card which
she never authorized frantically
contacting the bank Jane realized the
original email was a counterfeit or a
fake message with the malicious link
that inail credit card fraud this is a
classic example of a fishing attack
fishing attacks are a type of social
engineering where a fraudulent message
is sent to a Target on the premise of
arriving from a trusted Source its basic
purpose is to trick the victim into
revealing sensitive information like
passwords and payment information it's
based on the word fishing which works on
the concept of baits if a supposed
victim catches the bait the attack can
go ahead which in our case makes Jane
the fish and the fishing emails the bait
if Jane never opened the malicious link
or was cautious about the email
authenticity an attack of this nature
would have been relatively
ineffective but how does the hacker gain
access to these credentials a fishing
attack starts with a fraudulent message
which can be transmitted via email or
chat applications even using SMS
conversations to impersonate legitimate
sources is known as smishing which is a
specific category of fishing attacks
irrespective of the manner of
transmission the message targets the
victim in a way that coaxes them to open
a malicious link and provide critical
information on the requisite website
more often than not the websites are
designed to look as authentic as
possible once the victims submit
information using the link be it a
password or credit card details the data
is sent to the hacker who designed the
Emil email and the fake website giving
him complete control over the account
whose password was just provided often
carried out in campaigns where an
identical fishing mail is sent to
thousands of users the rate of success
is relatively low but never zero between
2013 and 2015 corporate giants like
Facebook and Google were tricked off of
$100 million due to an extensive fishing
campaign where a known common associate
was impersonated by the hackers apart
from credit access some of these
campaigns Target the victim device and
install malware when clicked on the
malicious links which can later function
as a botn net or a target for ransomware
attacks there is no single formula for
there are multiple categories of fishing
attacks the issue with Jane where the
hacker stole her bank credentials falls
under the umbrella of deceptive fishing
a general email is sent out to thousands
of users in this category hoping some of
them fall prey to this scam spear
fishing on the other hand is a bit
customized version the targets are
researched before being sent an email
for example if you never had a Netflix
subscription sending you an email that
seems like the Netflix Team sends it
becomes pointless this is a potential
drawback of deceptive fishing techniques
on the other hand a simple screenshot of
a Spotify playlist being shared on
social media indicates a probable point
of entry the hacker can send counterfeit
messages to the Target user while
implying the source of such messages
being Spotify tricking them into sharing
private information since the hacker
already knows the target use of Spotify
the chances of victims taking the bait
increase substantially for more
important targets like CEOs and people
with a fortune on their back the
research done is 10-fold which can be
called a case of wailing the hackers
prepare and wait for the right moment to
launch their fishing attack often to
steal industry secrets for rival
companies or sell them off at a higher
price apart from just emails farming
focuses on fake websites that resemble
their original counterparts as much as
possible a prevalent method is to use
domain names like Facebook with a single
o or YouTube with no e these are
mistakes that people make when typing
the full URL in the browser leading them
straight to a counterfeit web page which
can fool them into submitting private
data a few more complex methods exist to
drive people onto fake websites like ARP
spoofing and DNS cache poisoning but
they are rarely carried out due to time
and resource constraints now that we
know how fishing attacks work let's look
at ways to prevent ourselves from
becoming victims while the implications
of a fishing attack can be extreme
protecting yourself against these is
relatively straightforward Jane could
have saved herself from credit card
fraud had she checked the link in the
email for authenticity and that it
redirected to a secure website that runs
on the https protocol even suspicious
messages shouldn't be entertained one
must also refrain from entering private
information on random websites or popup
Windows irrespective of how legitimate
they seem it is also recommended to use
secure anti-fishing browser extensions
like cloudfish to sniff out malicious
emails from legitimate ones the best way
to prevent fishing is browsing the
internet with care and being on alert
for malicious attempts at all times
start by learning about cross-site
scripting from a Layman's
perspective
cross-site scripting also known as xss
is a type of code injection attack that
occurs on the client side the attacker
intends to run harmful scripts in the
victim's web browser by embedding
malicious code in a genuine web page or
online application the real Attack takes
place when the victim hits the malicious
code infected web page or online
application the web page or application
serves as a vehicle for the malicious
script to be sent to the user's browser
forums message boards and and online
pages that enable comments are
vulnerable vehicles that are frequently
utilized for cross scripting
assaults a web page or web application
is vulnerable to xss if the output it
creates contains unsanitized user input
the victim's browser must then pass this
user input in VB script ActiveX Flash
and even CSS cross-side scripting
attacks are conceivable they are
nevertheless most ubiquitous in
JavaScript o to the fact that Javas
script is most important to most browser
experiences
nowadays the main purpose of this attack
is to steal the other users identity be
it via cookies session tokens and other
information in most of the cases this
attack is being used to steal the other
person's cookies as we know cookies help
us to log in automatically therefore
with the stolen cookies we can log in
with other identities and this is one of
the reasons why this attack is
considered as one of the riskiest
attacks it can be performed with
different client side programming
languages as
well cross side scripting is often
compared with similar client side
attacks as client side languages are
mostly being used during this however an
xss attack is considered riskier because
of its ability to damage even less
vulnerable
Technologies most often this attack is
performed in JavaScript and HTML
JavaScript is a programming language
that runs on web pages inside your
browser the client side code at
functionality and interactivity to the
web page and is used extensively on all
major applications and CMS platforms
unlike servers side languages such as
PHP JavaScript code runs inside your
browser and cannot impact the website
for other visitors it is sandboxed to
your own Navigator and can only perform
actions within your own browser window
while JavaScript is client site and does
not run on the server it can be used to
interact with the server by performing
background requests attackers can then
use these background requests to add
unwanted spam content to a web page
without refreshing it they can then
gather analytics about the client's
browser or perform actions
asynchronously the manner of attack can
range in a variety of phase it can be a
single link which the user must click on
to initiate a JavaScript piece of code
it can be used to show any piece of
images that can be later used as a front
end for malicious code being installed
as malware but the majority of Internet
users unaware of how metadata works or
the ways in which web requests are
called the chances of victims clicking
on a redirecting links is far too high
cross-side scripting can occur on the
malicious script executed at the
client's side using a fake page or even
a form that is displayed to the user on
websites with displayed advertisements
malicious emails can also be sent to the
victim these attacks occur when the
malicious user finds the vulnerable
parts of the website and sends it as
appropriate malicious input
now that we understand the basics of
cross-site scripting let us learn more
about how this kind of attack
works in the first place we have the
website or the web browser which is used
to show content to the victim or which
is the user in our case whenever the
user wants to grab some content from the
website the website asks the data from
the server the server provides this
information to the website and the web
browser which ultimately Rees the victim
how the hacker comes into play here it
passes on certain arguments to the web
browser which is can be then forwarded
back to the server or to the user at
hand the entire cross-site scripting
attack Vector means sending and
injecting malicious code or script this
attack can be performed in different
ways depending on the type of attack the
malicious script may be reflected on the
victim's browser or stored in the
database and executed every time when
the user calls the appropriate function
the main reason for this attack is
inappropriate users input validation
where the malicious input can get into
the output a malicious user can enter a
script which will be injected onto the
website's code then the browser is not
able to know if the executed code is
malicious or not therefore this
malicious script is being executed on
the victim's browser or any faked form
if that is being displayed for the users
there are many ways to trigger an xss
attack for example the execution could
be triggered automatically when the page
loads or when a user hovers over
specific elements of the page like
hyperlinks potential consequences of
cross-site scripting attacks include
capturing keystrokes of a user
redirecting a user to malicious websites
running web browser based exploits
obtaining cookie information of a user
who is logged into a website and many
more in some cases cross-side scripting
attack leads to complete compromise of
the victim's account attackers can trick
users into entering credentials on a
fake form which can then provide all
information to the attacker with the
basic working of a cross-side scripting
attack out of the way let us go over the
different ways hackers can leverage
vulnerable web applications to gather
information and eventually breach those
systems the prime purpose of Performing
xss attack is to steal the other
person's identity as mentioned it may be
cookies session tokens
Etc xss May also be used to display
faked Pages or forms for the victim
however this can be performed in several
ways we have a reflected attack this
attack occurs when a malicious script is
not being saved on the web server but is
reflected in the website results
reflected accss code is not being saved
permanently in this case the malicious
code is being reflected in any website
result the attack code can be included
in the faked URL or in the HTTP
parameters it can affect the victim in
in different ways by displaying fake
malicious page or by sending a malicious
email in a reflected cross-side
scripting example the input of a search
form is reflected on the page to show
what the search key was an attacker May
craft a URL that contains malicious code
and then spread the same URL via email
or social media a user who clicks on
this link opens the valid web
application which then runs the
malicious code in the browser the script
is not stored in the web application and
malicious code is shown only to one user
the user that opens the link executes
the stript and the attack is not
necessarily visible on the server s or
to the app owner
itself the next variant is a stored
cross-side scripting attacks this occurs
when a malicious script is being saved
on the web server
permanently this can be considered a
riskier attack since it has leverage for
more damage in this type of attack the
malicious code or script is being saved
on the server for example in the
database of the website it is executed
every time the users call the
appropriate
functionality this way stored accss
attack can affect many users also as the
script is being stored on the web server
it will affect the website for a longer
time in order to perform stored xss
attack the malicious scripts should be
sent through the vulnerable input form
for example can be a comment field or a
review
field this way the appropriate script
will be saved in the the database and
evaluated on the page load or
appropriate function
calling in a stored xss example the
script might have been submitted by an
input field to the web server which did
not perform a sufficient validation and
stores the script permanently in the
database the consequence of this might
be that the script is now being
delivered to all users visiting the web
application and for example able to gain
access to the user session
cookies in this attack the script is
permanently is St in the web app the
users visiting the app after the
information retrieve the script the
malicious code then exploits the flaws
in the web application and the script
and the attack is visible on the server
side or to the app owner as
well the third variant is Dom based
cross-site scripting attacks this type
of attack occurs when the Dom
environment is being changed but the
client side code does not change when
the Dom environment is being modified in
the victim's browser the client side
code executes differently in order to
get a better understanding of how xss
Dom attack is being performed Let Us
analyze the following example if there
is a website called texting.com we know
default is a parameter therefore in
order to perform xss Dom attack we
should send a script as
parameters a Dom based xss attack may be
successfully executed even when the
server does not embed any malicious code
into the web page by using a flaw in the
JavaScript EX executed in the browser
for example if the client site
JavaScript modifies the Dom tree of the
web page it can be based on an input
field or the get parameter without
validating the input this allows the
malicious code to be
executed the malicious code the exploits
flaws in the browser on the user side
and the script and the attack is not
necessarily visible on the server side
or to the app
owner by now it is clear that cross-site
script attacks are difficult to detect
and even tougher to fight against there
are however plenty of ways one can
Safeguard against such attacks let's go
through some of these preventive
measures like mentioned earlier exist
attacks are sometimes difficult to
detect however this can be changed if
you get some external help a way to
prevent accessus attacks is using
automated testing tools like crash test
security suit or actic security
suit still manual testing is highly
timec consuming and costly and therefore
not possible to be done for every
iteration of your web
application consequently your code
shouldn't be untested before any release
using automated security you can scan
your web application for cross-side
scripting and other critical
vulnerabilities before every release
this way you can ensure that your web
application live version is still
secured whenever you alter or add a
feature
input fields are the most common point
of entry for xss attack script therefore
you should always screen and validate
any information input into data fields
this is particularly important if the
data will be included as HTML output
this can be used to protect against
reflected exsus
attacks validation should occur on both
the client side and server site as an
added precaution this helps validating
the data before it's being sent to the
servers and can also protect against
persistent xss scripts this can be
accomplished using JavaScript xss
attacks only appear if any user input is
being displayed on the web page
therefore try to avoid displaying any
untrusted user input if possible if you
need to display user data restrict the
places where the user input might appear
any input displayed inside a JavaScript
tag or a URL shown on the site is much
more likely to be exploited than the
input that appears inside a division or
a span element inside the HTML body
protecting against accesss
vulnerabilities typically requires
properly escaping user provided data
that is placed on the page rather than
trying to determine if the data is user
provided and could be compromised we
should always play it safe and Escape
data whether it is user provided or not
unfortunately because there are many
different rules for escaping you still
must choose the proper type of escaping
before settling on a final code
encoding should be applied directly
before user controllable data is written
to a page because the context you're
writing into determines what kind of
encoding you need to use for example
values inside a JavaScript string
require a different type of escaping to
those in an HTML context sometimes
you'll need to apply multiple layers of
encoding in the correct order for
example to safely embed user input
inside an event handler you need to deal
with both JavaScript context and the
HTML context so you need to First
Unicode escape the input and then HTML
encoded content security policy or CSP
is a computer security standard
introduced to prevent cross-site
scripting click checking and other code
injection attacks resulting from the
execution of malicious content in The
Trusted web page context it is a
candidate recommendations of the w3c
working group on web application
security it's widely supported by modern
web browsers and provides a standard
method for website owners to declare
approved origins of content that browser
should be allowed to load on that
website HTTP only is an additional flag
included in a set cookie HTTP response
header using the HTTP only flag when
generating a cookie helps mitigate the
risk of client side script accessing the
protected cookie that is if the browser
supports it if the HTTP only flag is
included in the HTTP response header the
cookie cannot be accessed through a
client side script again this is if the
browser supports the flag as a result
even if a cross-side scripting flaw
exists and a user accidentally accesses
a link that exploits this flaw the
browser will not reveal the cookie to a
third party if a browser does not
support HTTP only and a website attempts
to set an HTTP only cookie the HTTP only
flag will be ignored byow the browser
thus creating a traditional script
accessibility cookie as a result the
cookie becomes vulnerable to theft of
modification by any malicious script
next on our docket is a live
demonstration where we solve a set of
cross-site scripting problems starting
from the basic level to the topmost
level six we're going to start at level
one in this web application it
demonstrates the common cause of cross
side scripting where user input is
directly included in the page without
proper
escaping if we interact with a
vulnerable application window here and
find a way to make it execute JavaScript
of our choosing we can take actions
inside the vulnerable window or directly
edit its URL bar this task needs only
basic knowledge let's see why the most
primitive injections work here right
away let's do a simple query and inspect
the resulting HTML
page I'm going to use this
phrase with a single quote as a special
character we can now inspect the HTML
page we can see here in this
line the special character single code
appears in the result over
here the provided query text is placed
directly in a b tag as in a body element
we need to perform a reflected xss into
the web application because they are
nonpersistent xss attacks and the
payload should be included in the URL to
perform successful
exploitation we can use any payload but
we're going to use the simple one to
perform an alert in this web application
it's simple and can be shown
easily just going to write the script
over
here
and going to press
search as you can see we have
successfully launched our first cross
side scripting attack we can see an
alert box popup with the necessary
message and a similar process can be
used to steal browser cookies and
passwords all with different
commands now we have the option to move
to level
two in this web application it shows
that how easily xss bugs can be
introduced in complex chat
applications chat app conversations are
stored in a database and retrieved when
a user wants to see the conversation
therefore if a malicious user inject
some JavaScript code all visitors will
be infected this kind of cross-site
scripting attack is is more powerful and
it is more riskier than reflected
crossed skting attacks and that's why is
known as stored
xss I posted my
query with a special character of a
single quote and this is what I
get whatever I typed in simply appeared
on the page right after I click on share
status let's see the
source
you can see here the text I posted seems
directly put inside a block code tag so
even a simple script tag we used in
level one should work here but it will
not let us examine the code to
understand
why we're going to toggle the code of
here and check the index.html
file important part
is line
32 the generated HTML fragment which is
the HTML variable in the code is added
to the male HTML using the inner HTML
method so when the browser passing this
HTML fragment it will not execute any
script tag defined within that HTML
fragment HTML parser will not execute a
script tag when it pares htmls via this
method this is why the script tag like
we used in level one is not going to
work work here our solution is to use
events events will execute the defined
javascripts we're going to use an image
over
here
and when we press on share
status in the above injection we are
loading an image that doesn't exist
which causes to trigger an on error
event in on error event the it will
execute our alert method with that we
are able to beat level two and we can
now move up to the next level in our
challenge
as you can see clicking on any tab
causes the tab number to be displayed in
the URL
fragment this hints that the value after
the hashtag controls the behavior of the
page that is it is an input variable to
confirm let's analyze the
code as you can see in line 43 inside
the event handling
the value provided after the hash in the
URL is directly passed onto the chew tab
method no input validation is being
performed the value passed to the choose
tab method is directly injected into the
IMG tag in line
17 this is an unsafe assignment and it
is the vulnerable part of the code now
all we have to do now is to craft a
payload that would adjust the IMG tag to
execute our JavaScript remember the
script tag from level one would not work
here since the variable HTML is used to
add the Dom dynamically hence the events
are ases here once again I will choose
to use the existing IMG tag and change
the source to something that doesn't
exist hence forcing it to fall into to
execute an on error even which I will
pass the
URL
once we visit that URL we can see that
our Java popup has opened up here with
the same message of xss level 3 has been
completed with this we can now move on
to level four which is going to present
a different kind of
attack in this we application there is a
timer on the page that means whatever
numbers we put in the Box a countdown
starts and then when it finishes the
application alerts that the countown
down is
finished and we can see the time is a
popup appearing over here and this
resets the timer again now it is obvious
that the value entered in the text box
is transferred to the server over the
timer parameter in the
URL let us examine the code to see how
the timer parameter is being
handled we're going to visit timer. HTML
over
here and we're going to check over here
in line
21 the start timer method is being
called in the onload event however the
timer parameter is being directly passed
to the start timer method we need to
perform a popup Alert in the web
application which escapes the content of
the function start timer without making
the JavaScript code the parameter value
is directly added to the start timer
method without any filtering what we can
try to do here is to inject an alert
function to be executed in inside the on
loone event along with the start timer
method we're going to remove this
argument and put our script over
here now when me press on create
timer and we have a popup with xss level
four
completed we can now move on to level
five
in this web application this application
xss is different cuz this challenge
description says cross-side scripting
isn't just about correctly escaping
data sometimes attackers can do bad
things even without injecting new
elements into the Dom it's kind of open
redirect cuz the attack payload is
executed as a result of modifying the
Dom environment in the victim's browser
this environment is used by the original
client side script so that the client
side code runs in an unexpected manner
the vulnerability can be easily detected
if the next Link in the signup page is
inspected the href attribute value of
next link is confirm which is exactly
the value of the next URL query
parameter
as you can see over here this means
using the next query parameter can be
used to inject a JavaScript code to the
HF attribute of the next link the
following is the best way to do it as
soon as the user clicks on the link the
script will be
triggered
going to press anything random and now
that we click next we can see the xss
level 5 that we had provided in the URL
as a parameter to the next
variable since the value of next
provided appears on a popup we can
consider the attacker success and move
on to the final level
six in this sub application it shows
some of the external Javascript is
received if you analyze the URL you can
see that the script is loaded already
the vulnerability lies within how the
code handles the value after the
hashtag if you check on line 45 the
value right after the hashtag
is taken as the gadget name and then in
line
48 the value is directly passed on to
the include Gadget method and in the
include Gadget method that we can see
over
here you can see in line
18 a script tag is created and the URL
Gadget name parameter value is directly
used as the source attribute of the
script tag in line
28 this means we can completely control
the The Source attribute of the script
tag that is being
created that is with this vulnerability
we can inject our own Javascript file
into the code we can inject a URL of our
own hosted JavaScript into the web
application's URL after the hashtag and
the URL should not be using https but
anything like that to bypass the regular
expression for security
checking going to remove the prored
URL
and we're going to load our own
Javascript
file finally we have reached the end of
our challenge
we completed six different varieties of
cross scripting attacks and used
different solutions for all of the six
questions with work from home being the
norm in today's era people spend
considerable amount of time on the
internet often without specific measures
to ensure a secure session apart from
individuals organizations worldwide that
host data and conduct business over the
internet are always at the risk of a DS
attack these DS attacks are are getting
more extreme with hackers getting easy
access to botet farms and compromised
devices as can be seen in the graph
three of the six strongest DS attacks
were launched in 2021 with the most
extreme attack occurring just last year
in 2020 lately cyber criminals have been
actively seeking out new services and
protocols for amplifying these DS
attacks active involvement with hacked
machines and botet allow further
penetration into the consumer space
allowing much more elaborate attack
campaigns apart from General users
multinational corporations have also had
their fair share of problems GitHub a
platform for software developers was the
target of a DS attack in 2018 widely
suspected to be conducted by Chinese
authorities this attack went on for
about 20 minutes after which the systems
were brought into a stable condition it
was the strongest DS attack to date at
the time and made a lot of companies
reconsider the security practices to
combat such attacks even after years of
experimentation Doos attacks are still
at large and can affect anyone in the
consumer and corporate space hey
everyone this is B from Simply learn and
welcome to this video on what is a DS
attack let's learn more about what is a
Dos
attack a distributed denial of service
attack or dos is when an attacker or
attackers attempt to make it impossible
for a service to be delivered this can
be achieved by thating access to
virtually anything servers devices
Services networks applications and even
specific transactions within
applications in a Dos attack it's one
system that is sending the malicious
data or requests a DS attack comes from
multiple systems generally these attacks
work by Drowning a system with requests
for data this could be sending a web
server so many requests to serve a page
that it crashes under the demand or it
could be a database being hit with a
high volume of queries the result is
available internet bandwidth CPU and RAM
capacity become
overwhelmed the impact could range from
a minor annoyance from disrupted
services to experiencing entire websites
applications or even entire businesses
taking offline more often than not these
attacks are launched using machines in a
bot net a botnet is a network of devices
that can be triggered to send requests
from a remote source of known as the
command and control
center the bots in the network attack a
particular Target thereby hiding the
original perpetrator of the DS campaign
but how do these devices come under a
botnet and what are the requests being
made to the web servers let's learn more
about these and how dos attack
work a Dos attack is a two-phase process
in the first phase a hacker creates a
bot net of devices simply put a vast
network of computers are hacked via
malware ransomware or just simple social
engineering these devices become a part
of the botn net which can be triggered
any time to start bombarding a system or
a server on the instruction of the
hacker that created the bot net the
devices in this networks are called Bots
or zombies in the second phase a
particular Target is selected for the
attack when the hacker finds the right
time to attack all the zombies in the
botnet network send these requests the
target thereby taking up all the servers
available bandwidth these can be simple
ping requests or complex attacks like SN
flooding and UDP flooding the aim is to
overwhelm them with more traffic than
the server or the network can
accommodate the goal is to render the
website or service
inoperable there's a lot of wiggle room
when it comes to the type of DS attack a
hacker can go with depending on the
target's vulnerability we can choose one
of the three broad categories of DS
attacks
volume based attacks use massive amounts
of bogus traffic to overwhelm a resource
it can be a website or a server they
include icmp udap and spoofed packet
flood attacks the size of volume based
attack is measured in bits per second
these attacks focus on clogging all the
available bandwidth for the server
thereby cutting the supply short several
requests are sent to the server all of
which warrant a reply thereby not
allowing the target to cater to the
general legitimate
users next we have the protocol level
attacks these attacks are meant to
consume essential resources of the
target server they exhaust the load
balancers and firewalls which are meant
to protect the system against the dors
attacks these protocol attacks include
SN floods and Smurf DDOS among others
and the size is measured in packets per
second for example in an SSL handshake
server replies to the Hello message sent
by the hacker which will be the client
in this case but since the IP is poofed
and leads nowhere the server gets stuck
in an endless loop of sending the
acknowledgement without any end in
sight finally we have the application
Level attacks application layer attacks
are conducted by flooding applications
with maliciously crafted requests the
size of application layer attacks is
measured in request per second these are
relatively sophisticated attacks that
Target the application and operating
system level
vulnerabilities they prevent the
specific applications from delivering
necessary information to users and hog
the network bandid up to the point of a
system crash examples of such an attack
are HTTP flooding and bgp hijacking a
single device can request data from a
server using HTTP post or get without
any
issues however when the requisite botnet
is instructed to bombard the server with
thousands of requests the database band
and gets jammed and it eventually
becomes unresponsive and
unusable but what about the reasons for
such an attack there are multiple lines
of thought as to why a hacker decides to
launch a Dos attack on unsuspecting
targets let's take a look at a few of
them the first option is to gain a
competitive Advantage many dos attacks
are conducted by hacking communities
against rival groups some organizations
hire such communities to stagger their
Rivals resources at a network level to
gain an advantage in the playing field
since being a victim of a dets attack
indicates a lack of security the
reputation of such a company takes a
significant hit allowing the rivals to
cover up some
ground secondly some hackers launch
these DS attacks to hold multinational
corporations at Ransom the resources are
jammed and the only way to clear the way
is if the target company agrees to pay a
designated amount of money to the
hackers even a few minutes of inactive
ity is detrimental to a company's
reputation in the global market and it
can cause a spiral effect both in terms
of market value and product security
index most of the time a compromise is
reached and the resources are freed
after a while DS attacks have also found
use in the political segment certain
activists tend to use dedos attacks to
voice their opinion spreading the word
online is much faster than any local
Rally or Forum primarily political these
are attacks also focus on online
communities ethical dilemmas or even
protest against corporations let's take
a look at a few ways that companies and
individuals can protect themselves
against redos
attacks the company can employ load
balancers and firewalls to help protect
the data from such attacks load
balancers reroute the traffic from one
server to another in a DS attack this
reduces the single point of failure and
adds resiliency to the server data a
firewall blocks unwanted traffic into a
system and manages the number of
requests made at a definite rate it
checks for multiple attacks from a
single IP and occasional slowdowns to
detect a DS attack in
action early detection of a Dos attack
goes a long way in recovering the data
lost in such an event once you've
detected the attack you will have to
find a way to respond for example you
will have to work on dropping the
malicious DS traffic before it reaches
your server so that it doesn't throttle
and exhaust your bandwidth here's where
you will filter the traffic so that only
legitimate traffic reaches the server by
intelligent routing you can break the
remaining traffic into manageable chunks
that can be handled by your cluster
resources the most important stage in
DOS mitigation is where you will look
for patterns of Dos attacks and use
those to analyze and strengthen your
mitigation techniques for example
blocking an IP that's repeatedly found
to be offending is a first step
Cloud providers like Amazon web services
and Microsoft Azure who offer high
levels of cyber security including
firewalls and threat monitoring software
can help protect your assets and network
from DS criminals the cloud also has
greater bandw than most private networks
so it is likely to fail if under the
pressure of increased DS
attacks additionally reputable Cloud
providers offer Network redundancy
duplicating copies of your data systems
and equipment
so that if your service becomes
corrupted or unavailable due to a DS
attack you can switch to a secure access
on backed up versions without missing a
beat one can also increase the amount of
bandwidth available to a host server
being targeted since DS attacks
fundamentally operate on the principle
of overwhelming systems with heavy
traffic simply provisioning extra
bandwidth to handle unexpected traffic
spikes can provide a measure of
protection this solution can prove
expensive as a lot of that bandwidth is
going to go unused most of the
time a Content delivery Network or a CDN
distributes your content and boost
performance by minimizing the distance
between your resources and end users it
stores the cached version of your
content in multiple locations and this
eventually mitigates dos attacks by
avoiding a single point of failure when
the attacker is trying to focus on a
single Target popular CDN include acomi
CDN Cloud flare AWS cloudfront
Etc let's start with our demo regarding
the effects of DS attacks on a system
for our demo we have a single device
that will attack a Target making it a
Dos attack of sorts once a bot net is
ready multiple devices can do the same
and eventually emulate a DS attack to do
so we will use the virtualization
software called VMware with an instance
of parot security operating system
running for a Target machine we will be
running another vmw instance of a
standard Linux distribution known as
Linux light in a Target device we can
use wire shockk to determine when the
attack begins and see the effects of the
attack
accordingly this is Linux light which is
a target machine and this is parro
security which is used by the hacker
when trying to launch a DS attack this
is just one of the dros that can be
used to launch the attack we must first
find the IP address of our
Target so to find the IP address we open
the
terminal we use the command if
config and here we can find the IP
address now remember we're launching
this attack in VMware now the both the
instances of parro security and Linux
light are being run on my local network
so the address that you can see here is
192.168
72129 which is a private address this IP
cannot be accessed from outside the
network basically anyone who is not
connected to my Wi-Fi when launching
attacks with public servers or public
addresses it will have a public IP
address that does not belong to the
subnet once we have the IP
address we can use a tool called
hping
3 hping 3 is an open-source packet
generator and analyzer for the TCP IP
protocol to check what are the effects
of an attack we will be using wire shark
Yar is a network traffic analyzer we can
see whatever traffic that is passing
through the Linux light drro is being
displayed over here with the IP address
the source IP and the destination IP as
to where the request is being
transferred to once we have the Dos
attack launched you can see the results
coming over here from The Source IP
which will be par security Now to launch
the hping 3 command we need to give
pseudo access to the console which is
the root
AIS now we have the root axis for the
console the hping 3 command will have a
few arguments to go with it
which are as you can see on the
screen minus s and a
flood a hyphen
V hyphen p80 and the IP address of the
target which is 192 168 72.
1229 in this command we have a few
arguments that such as the minus s which
specifies SN packets like in an SSL
handshake we have the SN request that
the client sends to the server to
initiate a connection The Hyphen flood
aims to ignore the replies that the
server will send back to the client in
response to the SN packets here the par
security OS is the client and Linux
slide being the
server minus v stands for verbosity as
in where we will see some output when
the requests are being sent
The Hyphen p80 stands for Port 80 which
we can replace the port number if we
want to attack a different port and
finally we have the IP address of our
Target as of right now if we check wire
shock it is relatively clear and there
is no indication of a DS attack incoming
now once we launch the attack over
here we can see the requests coming in
from this IP which is 192 168 72.1
128 till now even if the network is
responsive and so is Linux
light the requests keep on coming and we
can see the
HTTP flooding has started in flood
mode after a few seconds of this attack
continuing the server will start
shutting down now remember Linux light
is a drro that can focus on and that
serves as a
backend now remember Linux light is a
drro and such Linux drr are served as
backend to many servers across the world
for example a few seconds have passed
from the attack now the system has
become completely irresponsive this has
happened due to the huge number of
requests that came from par
security you can see whatever I press
nothing is responded even the wire Shar
has stopped capturing new request
because the CPU usage right now is
completely 100% and at this point of
time anyone who is trying to request
some information from this Linux drro or
where this Linux drro is being used as a
backend for a server or a database
cannot access anything else the system
has completely stopped responding and
any request any legitimate request from
legitimate users will be
dropped once you stop the attack over
here it takes a bit of time to set SLE
down now remember it's still out of
control but eventually the traffic dies
down and the system regains its strength
it is relatively easy to gauge right now
the effect of a Dos attack now remember
this Linux light is just a VM instance
actual website servers and web databases
they have much more bandwidth and are
very secure and it is tough to break
into that is why we cannot use a single
machine to break into them that is where
a DS attack comes into play what we did
right now is a Dos attack as in a single
system is being used to penetrate a
Target server using a single request now
when a Dos attack multiple systems such
as multiple par security instances or
multiple zombies or bots in a botnet
network can attack a Target server to
completely shut down the machine and
drop any legitimate request thereby
rendering the service and the target
completely unusable and in
operable as a final note we would like
to remind that this is for educational
purposes only and we do not endorse any
attacks on any domains only test this on
servers and networks that you have
permission to test on cyber security has
become one of the most rigid Industries
in the last decade while simultaneously
being the most challenged with every
aspect of corporate culture going online
and embracing cloud computing there is a
plethora of critical data circulating
through the the internet all worth
billions of dollars to the right person
increasing benefits require more complex
attacks and one of these attacks is a
Brute Force attack a brute force or
known as Brute Force cracking is the
Cyber attack equivalent of trying every
key on your key ring and eventually
finding the right one Brute Force
attacks are simple and reliable there is
no prior knowledge needed about the
victim to start an attack most of the
systems falling pre to Brute Force
attacks are actually well
secured at Packers let a computer do the
work that is trying different
combinations of usernames and passwords
until they find the one that works due
to this repeated trial and error format
the strength of password matters a great
dral although with enough time and
resources brute force will break a
system since they run multiple
combinations until they find the right
passcode hey everyone this is B from
Simply learn and welcome to this video
on what is a Brute Force attack let's
begin with learning about Brute Force
attacks in detail
a Brute Force attack also known as an
exhaustive search is a cryptographic
hack that relies on guessing possible
combinations of targeted password until
the current password is discovered it
can be used to break into online
accounts encrypted documents or even
Network peripheral devices the longer
the password the more combinations that
will need to be tested a Brute Force
attack can be timec consuming and
difficult to perform if methods such as
data aisc are used and at times
downright
impossible however if the password is
weak it could merely take seconds with
hardly any effort dictionary attacks are
an alternative to Brute Force attacks
where the attacker already has a list of
usernames and passwords that need to be
tested against the target it doesn't
need to create any other combinations on
its own dictionary attacks are much more
reliable than brute force in a real
world context but the usefulness depends
entirely on the strength of passwords
being used by the general population
addtion there is a three-step process
when it comes to brute forcing a system
let's learn about each of them in
detail in step one we have to settle on
a tool that we are going to use for
brute forcing there are some popular
names on the market like
hashcat Hydra and John the Ripper while
each of them has its own strength and
weaknesses each of them perform well
with the right configuration all of
these tools come pre-installed with
certain Linux distributions that cater
to penetration testers and cyber
security analysts like K Linux and parro
security after deciding what tool to use
we can start generating combinations of
alpha numeric variables whose only
limitation is the number of characters
for example while using Hydra a single
six-digit password will create 900,000
passwords with only digits involved add
alphabets and symbols to that sample
space and that number numbers grows
exponentially the popular tools allow
customizing this process let's say the
hacker is aware of the password being a
specific eight-digit word containing
only letters and symbols this will
substantially increase the chances of
being able to get the right password
since we remove the time taken to
generate the longer ones we omit the
need for including digits in such
combinations these small tweaks go a
long way in organizing an efficient
Boost Force attack since running all the
combination with no filters will
dramatically reduce the odds of finding
the right credentials in time in the
final step we run these combinations
against the file or service that is
being broken we can try and break into a
specific encrypted document a social
media account or even devices at home
that connect to the internet let's say
there is a Wi-Fi router the generated
passwords are then fed into the
connection one after the other it is a
long and uous process but the work is
left to the computer other than than
someone manually clicking and checking
each of these
passcodes any password that doesn't
unlock the router is discarded and The
Brute Force tool simply moves on to the
next one this keeps going on until we
find the right combination which unlocks
the
router sometimes reaching the success
stage takes days and weeks which makes
it cumbersome for people with low
computing power at their disposal
however the ability to crack any system
in the world purely due to bad password
habits is very appealing and the general
public tends to stick with simple and
easy to ous
passwords now that we have a fair idea
about how Brute Force Works let's see if
you can answer this question we learned
about how complex passwords are tougher
to crack by Brute Force among the ones
listed on the screens which one do you
believe will take the longest to be
broken when using Brute Force tools
leave your answers in the comment
section and we will get back to you with
the correct option next
week
let's move on to the harmful effects of
getting a system compromised due to
Brute Force
attacks a hacked laptop or mobile can
have social media accounts logged in
giving the hackers free access to the
victim's connections it has been
reported on multiple occasions where
compromised Facebook accounts are
sending malicious links and attachments
to people on their friends
list one of the significant reasons for
hacking malware infusion is best done
when spread from multiple devices
similar to Distributing spam this
reduces the chance of circling back the
source to a single device which belongs
to the hacker once brute forced A system
can spread malware via email attachments
sharing links file upload via FTP
Etc personal information such as credit
card data usage habits private images
and videos are all stored in our systems
be it in plain format or root folders a
compromised laptop means easy access to
these information that can be further
used to impersonate the victim regarding
Bank verification among other
things once a system is hacked it can
also be used as a mail server that
distributes spam across lists of victims
since the hack machines all have
different IP addresses and Mac addresses
it becomes challenging to trace the spam
back to the original hacker with so many
harmful implications arising from a boot
Force attack it's imperative that the
General Public must be protected against
such let's learn about some of the ways
we can prevent ourselves from becoming a
victim of Brute Force
attacks using passwords consisting of
alphabets letters and numbers have a
much higher chance of its standing Brute
Force attacks thanks to the sheer number
of combinations they can produce the
longer the password the less likely it
is that a hacker will devote the time
and resources to bruteforce them having
alpha numeric passwords also allows the
user to keep different passwords for
different websites this is to ensure
that if a single account or password is
compromised due to a breach or a hack
the rest of the accounts are isolated
from the
incident two-factor authentication
involves receiving a one-time password
on a trusted device before a new login
is allowed this OTB can be obtained
either via email SMS or specific toofa
applications like Ai and Aegis email and
SMS based otps are considered relatively
less secure nowadays due to the ease
with which SIM cards can be duplicated
and mailboxes can be hacked applications
that are specifically made for 2A course
are much more reliable and
secure captur are used to stop Bots from
running through web pages precisely to
prevent brute forcing through their
website since Brute Force tools are
automated forcing the hacker to solve
capture for every iteration of a
password manually is very challenging
the capture system can filter out these
automated Bots that keep refreshing the
page with different credentials thereby
reducing the chances of BR Force
considerably a definite rule that locks
the account being hacked for 30 minutes
after a specific number of attempts is a
good way to prevent Brute Force attempts
many websites lock account for 30
minutes after three failed password
attempts to secure the account against
any such attack on an additional note
some websites also send an email
instructing the user that there have
been three insecure attempts to log into
the
website let's look at a demonstration of
how Brute Force attacks work in a real
world situation the world has gone
Wireless with WiFi taking the re in
every household it's natural that the
security will always be up for debate to
further tou the security index and
understand Brute Force attacks you will
attempt to break into the password of a
Wi-Fi router for that to happen we first
need to capture a handshake file which
is a connection file from the Wi-Fi
router to a connecting device like a
mobile or a laptop the operating system
used for this process is parot security
a Linux distribution that is catered to
penetration testers all the tools being
used in this demo can easily be found
pre-installed in this operating system
if getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free visit scale up by simply learn
click on the link in the description to
know
more to start demo we're going to use a
tool called airgeddon which is made to
hack into wireless network
specifically at this point it's going to
check for all the necessary scripts that
are installed in the
system to crack into a Wi-Fi and to
capture the handshake file we're going
to need an external network card the
significance of the external network
card is a managed mode and a monitor
mode for now the WL X1 named card is my
external network adapter which I'm going
to select to be able to capture data
over the air we're going to need to put
it in monitor mode as you can see above
it's written it is in managed mode right
now so we're going to select option two
which is to put the interface in monitor
mode and it name is now W l0
monitor the monitor mode is necessary to
capture data over the air that is the
necessary reason why we need an external
card since a lot of inbuilt cards that
come with the laptops and the systems
they cannot have a monitor mode
installed once we select the mode we can
go into the fifth which is the handshake
tools
menu in the first step we have to
explore for targets and it is written
that monitor mode is necessary to select
a Target so let's explore for
targets and press
enter we have to let this run for about
60 seconds to get a fair idea about the
networks that are currently working in
this locality for example this ESS ID is
supposed to be the Wi-Fi name that we
see when connecting to a network go24
recover me these are all the names that
we see on our mobile when trying to
search for the Wi-Fi this BSS ID is
supposed to be an identifier somewhat
like a MAC address that identifies this
network from other devices the channels
features on one or two or there are some
many channels that the networks can
focus
on this here is supposed to be a client
that is connected to one such Network
for example the station that you can see
5626 this is supposed to be the MAC
address of the device that is connected
to a router this BS ID is supposed to be
which wi-fi it is connected to for
example 5895 d8 is this one which is the
go24 router so we already know which
router has a device connected to it and
we can use our attack to capture this
handshake now that we it has already run
for 1 minute now that we press contrl
C it will be asked to select a Target
see it has already selected the number
five which is the ge24 router as the one
with client so it is easy to run an
attack on and it is easy to capture a
handshake
for select Network 5 and we run a
capture
handshake it says we have a valid WPA
WPA2 Network Target selected and that
the script can
continue now to capture the handshake we
have a couple of attacks a do or a do
air replay attack what this attack does
is kick the clients out of the network
in return When the try to reconnect to
the Wi-Fi as they are configured that
way that when a client is disconnected
it tries to reconnect it immediately it
tries to capture a handshake file which
in turn contains the security key which
is necessary to initiate the
handshake for our demo let's go with the
second option that is the do air replay
attack select a timeout value let's say
we give it 60
seconds and we start the
script we can see it capturing data from
the ge24 network and here we go we have
the WPA handshake
file once the handshake file is captured
can actually close this and here we go
congratulations in order to capturing a
handshake it has verified that a pmk ID
from the target network has successfully
been captured this is the file that is
already stored a do cap file for the
path we can let's say we can keep it in
a
desktop okay we give the
path and the Hand Shi file is generated
we can already see a Target over here
same go24 router with the BSS
ID now if we return to its main
menu we already have the handshake file
captured with us now our job is to Brute
Force into that handshake capture file
the capture file is often encrypted with
the security key of the Wi-Fi network if
we know how to decrypt it we will
automatically get the security key so
let's go to the offline WPA wp2 decrypt
menu since we'll be cracking personal
networks we can go with option
one now to run the Brute Force tool we
have two options either we can go with
the air crack or we can go with the
hashcat let's go with airc plus crunch
which is a Brute Force attack against a
handshake file we can go with option
two it can already detect the capture
file that we have
generated so we select
yes the BSS ID is the one which denotes
the ge24 router so we're going to select
yes as well the minimum length of the
key for example it has already checked
that the minimum length of a Wi-Fi
security key which is a WPA2 psk key
will always be more than eight digits
and Below 64 digits so we have to select
something in between this range so if we
already know let's say that the password
is at least 10 digits we can go with the
minimum length as 10 and as a rough
guess let's say we put the maximum
length as
20 the character set that we're going to
use for checking the password will
affect the time taken to Brute Force for
example if you already know that or we
have seen a user use the password while
connecting to the router as something
that has only numbers and symbols then
we can choose accordingly let's say if
we go with only uppercase characters and
numeric
characters go with option
seven and it's going to start
decrypting so how aircrack is working
right here you can see this pass phrase
over here the first five or six digits
are a it starts working its way from the
end from the last last character it
keeps trying every single combination
you can see the last the fourth
character from the right side the D
it'll eventually turn to
e because it keeps checking up every
single character from the end this will
keep going on until all the single
characters are tested and every single
combination is tried out since the
handshake file is encrypted using the
security key that is the WPA2 key of the
router whichever P phrase is able to
decrypt the handshake key complet
completely will be the key of the Wi-Fi
router this is the way we can Brute
Force into Wi-Fi routers anywhere in the
world cyber attacks are frequently
making headlines in today's digital
environment at any time everyone who
uses a computer could become a victim of
a Cyber attack there are various sorts
of cyber attacks ranging from fishing to
password attacks in this video we'll
look into one such attack that is known
as botet but before we begin if you love
watching Tech videos subscribe to our
Channel and hit the Bell icon never to
miss an update to begin with let's take
a look at some of the famous botet
attacks the first one is Mirai botet
which is a malicious program designed to
attack vulnerable iot devices and infect
them to form a network of bots that on
command perform basic and medium level
denial of service attacks then we have
the zo bot is specifically designed for
attacking the system system for Bank
related information and data now let's
see what exactly a botnet
is botnet refers to a network of
hijacked interconnected devices that are
installed with malicious codes known as
malware each of these infected devices
are known as Bots and the hijack
criminal known as bot harder remotely
controls them the Bots are used to
automate large scale attacks including
Data Theft server failure malware
propagation
and Deni of service
attacks now that we know what exactly a
bot net is let's dive deeper into
learning how bot net works during the
preparation of a botnet network the
first step involves preparing the botn
net Army after that the connection
between the botnet Army and the control
server established and the end the
launching of the attack is done by the B
Herer let's understand through a
illustration
firstly we have a bot Herer that
initiates the attack according to the
control server commands the devices that
are infected with the malware programs
and begins to attack the infected system
let's see some details regarding the
preparation of the bot net
Army the first step is known as the
prepping the bot net Army the first step
is creating a botn net to infect as many
as connected devices as possible this
ensures that there are enough Bots to
carry out the attack this way it creates
Bots either by exploiting the security
gaps in the software or websites or
using fishing attacks they are often
deployed through troan
horses for the next step we have
establishing the connection once it
hacks the device as per previous step it
infects it with a specific malware that
connects the device back to the control
bot server a bot H Herer uses command
programming to drive the bot's
actions and the last step is known as
launching the attack once infected a bot
allows access to atmin level operation
like Gathering and stealing of data
reading and rewriting the system data
monitoring user activities performing
denial of service attacks including
other cyber
crimes now let's take a look at the
important
architecture the first type is known as
client server model the client server
model is a traditional model that
operates with the help of a command and
control center server and communication
protocols like
IRC when the B Herer issues a command to
the server it is then related to the
clients to perform malicious
actions then we have peer-to-peer model
here controlling the infected Bots
involves a peer-to-peer Network that
relies on a decentralized approach that
is the BS are tropological
interconnected and act as both CNC
servers that is the server and the
client to the hackers adopt this
approach to avoid detection and single
point
failure in the end we will see some
points on some countermeasure against
bot net
attacks the first step is to have
updated drivers and system updates after
that we should avoid clicking random
popups or links that we often see on the
internet and lastly having certified
antivirus anti- spyware softwares and
firewall installed into a system will
protect against malware attack the
internet is an endless source of
information and data still in some cases
we come across some occurrences like
cyber attacks hacking force entry which
may affect a Time on the web hi everyone
and welcome to the simply La Channel
today we will discuss a topic that
secretly records our input data that is
known as key loggers but before we begin
if you like watching Tech videos
subscribe to our Channel and hit the
Bell icon to never miss an
update to understand the key logging
problem better let's take a look at an
example this is June she works in a
business firm where she manages the
company's data
regularly this is Jacob from the
information Department who is here to
inform her about some of the security
protocols during the briefing she
informed him about some of the problems
her system was facing with which
included slow re action speed and
unusual internet
activity as Jacob heard about the
problems with the system he thinks of
the possibility what could be the reason
behind these problems a system was
facing
with the conclusion that he came across
was the key logging
issue unknown to the problem her system
was facing with she asked him about some
of the details regarding
it for today's topic we learn what
exactly key loggers are and how they
affect our system what are the harmful
effects that key logging can bring into
the system to begin with we learn what
exactly the key logging program
is as the name suggests key logger is a
malicious program or a tool that is
designed to record key strokes that are
typed during data input and record them
into a lock file then the same program
secretly sends these loog files to its
origin where they can be used used for
malicious acts by the
hacker now that we know what the key
logging program is let's take a look how
they enter into the
system searching for a suitable driver
for a system can often lead to the
installation of the key loging program
into the system if we often visit
suspicious sites and uncertified
software are installed into our system
then if we use unknown links or visiting
unknown websites which come through
unknown addresses can also be a reason
behind the key logging issue entering
into the system and lastly there are
often cases where different popups that
we often see on social sites or
different media sites can lead to the
installation of key loging program into
our
system now that we know how the problem
gets into the system let's take a look
how to identify whether the system is
infected by the key logging
issue the key logging issue can be
identified if there are often cases when
a keyboard lags behind the system the
data that we enter sometimes is stuck in
between when we type through the
input then there are cases when the
system freeze occurs unknowingly to what
exactly could be the reason behind them
and also there are delayed reaction time
for different applications that run on
the system and lastly there are
different cases when we often see
suspicious internet activity on the
system that we don't know about this
could lead to the identification of a
problem into the
system now we'll take a look at
different types of key loggers that are
present on the net which can harm our
system
differently the first problem that key
loggers arounds is API based the most
common key logging case which uses AP to
keep a log of the type data and share it
to its origin for malicious purposes
each time we press a key the key logger
intercepts the signal and logs it then
we have form grabbing based key loggers
as the name suggest they are based key
loggers that store the form data that is
if we often use web forms or different
kinds of forms to enter different data
they can be recorded into the system by
the program and send it to its
origin then we have kernel based key
loggers these key loggers are installed
deeply into the operating system where
they can hide from different antivirus
if not checked properly and they record
the data that we type on the keyboard
and send it to its
origin and lastly we have Hardware Key
loggers these key loggers are present
directly into the hardware that is they
are embedded into system where they
record the data that we type on the
keyboard now let's take a look how
hackers differentiate different type of
recorded data and exploit
them when hackers receive information
about the target they might use it to
Blackmail the target which may affect
the personal life of the Target and also
blackmail them for different money
related
issues then in case of company data that
is recorded by the key logging program
can also affect the economic value of
the company in the market which may lead
to the downfall of the
company also in some cases the key
logging program can also log data about
military Secrets which may include
nuclear codes or security protocols
which are necessary to maintain the
security of a
country now let's take a look whether
mobile devices get infected with the key
logging issue or not
in the case of hand devices infection of
key loggers are low in comparison to the
computer systems as they use onscreen
keyboard or virtual
keyboard but in some cases we often see
different tyes of malicious programs
getting installed into the hand device
if we often visit different uncertified
websites or illegal websites or torrent
sites and also the device that is
infected with the key logging issue or
different kind of malicious program can
often lead to the exploitation of data
that includes photos emails or important
files by the hacker or the Cyber
criminal that install the particular
malicious program into the
system now to prevent a system from
getting infected by the key locking
program let's take a look at different
points the first point includes using of
different antivirus softwares or tools
which can prevent the entering a
malicious program into the
system then keeping system security
protocols regularly updated is also a
good
habit and lastly using virtual keyboard
to input our sensitive data which may
include Bank details login details or
different passwords related to different
websites now that we have some
understanding about the topic of key
loggers let's take a look at the demo to
further increase the knowledge about the
topic for the first step we have to
download some of the important libraries
that are required into the
system which
is this library now we'll run
it the system says the library is
already installed into the
system now let's take a look what
exactly modules are required from the
particular
library from this Library we'll
import the keyboard module which will
help us to record the data that we type
on the
keyboard now from the same we'll also
import key
module and The Listener
module and
also the logging module which will help
us to record the data into a log
file for the next part we'll write a
piece of code that will allow us to save
the data that is recorded by the program
into a text file that will be named as
keor log text file along with the date
and time stamp let's take a
look now we'll provide it with the file
name that will be given
as key log do txt
file and also so the part where the
format of the data is
recorded put the brackets over here to
contain the file name now we'll write
the format in which the data data will
be recorded into the log file which will
be given
as the format would be the message and
the time stamp which would be given
as along with the time
stamp
as
percentage and ending it with the
bracket now for the next step we'll
design two of the functions that will be
used into the program that will be
termed as while press function and while
release function let's take a
look while press function
fun would be a function that will come
into play when the keyboard key has been
pressed
is
and this would go for the format that we
designed
in the above
line
and
logging the Pressed
key
info for string file to be
recorded into the lock file
now now we'll design a function that is
while release
that will come into play
when the Escape key has been pressed
that is the program will terminate
itself and the program will stop from
running and in the
end we require for the functioning of
the program to Loop these functions that
is while press and while release to
continue its
cycle that will be going for while press
and
on release will contain while
release
function
as listen
now and now this part would join the
different threads and store them to the
lock file now that we have completed the
code for the program let's run
it we have to wait for a moment so the
program runs it
now to verify the program let's open
notepad and on the notepad we'll
write hello hello
world which will be the basic whether
the program is working or not let's take
a
look and we'll go for the main page on
Jupiter notebook and refresh the page go
to the
bottom over here we see the key log text
that is a text file that we created
let's open
it and over here we have the data that
is created as we start started with Note
then this is the hello world part that
we created just
now which shows that the program we
created is working properly now that we
have reached the end of the module let's
take a look at the summary firstly we
learn what exactly key loggers are then
we understood what different modes are
present how the system get infected with
the key logging problem then we learned
how to detect the problem in into our
system then we learn what different
types of key loggers are present on the
net we also understood how hackers use
the recorded data from the program and
we also learn whether mobile devices get
infected with the key logging problem or
not and lastly we understood what
different points can be taken to prevent
the entering of the key logging problem
into the system before we learn about
the Pegasus platform let us understand
what spyware is and it's working spyware
is a category of malare web that can
gather information regarding a user or a
device straight from the host machine it
is mostly spread by malicious links via
email or chat applications when a link
with the malware is received clicking on
this link will activate the spyware
which allows the hacker to spy on all
our user information with some spy
systems even clicking on the link isn't
necessary to trigger the malicious
payload this can ultimately cause
security complications and further loss
of privacy one such SP system that is
making the rounds in the tech industry
today is Pegasus the Pegasus is a
spyware system developed by an Israeli
company known as the NSO group it runs
on mainly mobile devices spanning across
the major operating systems like the
Apple's IOS on iPhone and the standard
Android versions this is not a newly
developed platform since Pegasus has
existed since as early as 2016 a highly
intricate spy program that can track
user location read text messages scan
through mobile files access device
camera and microphone to record voice
and video Pegasus has all the tools
necessary to enforce surveillence for
any client that wishes to buy its
services initially the NSO group had
designed the software to be used against
terrorist factions of the world with
more and more encrypted communication
channels coming to the Forefront Pegasus
was designed to maintain control over
the data transmission that can be a
threat to National Security
unfortunately the people who bought the
software had come complete control over
who how and up to what level they can
put surveillance limits on eventually
the primary clients became Sovereign
Nations spying on Public Information
that is supposed to stay private became
really easy with this service multiple
devices can be affect With the same spy
system to create a network information
this network keeps feeding data to the
host to understand how a network can be
created let's know how a mobile device
can be affected by Pegasus we all commun
Comm unicate with friends and family
over instant messaging applications and
email in some instances if you check
your inbox on a regular basis you must
have noticed that we received some spam
emails that the mail providers like
Gmail and Yahoo can just filter into the
spam folder some of these messages
bypass this filter and make their way
into a person's inbox they look like
generic emails which are supposed to be
safe the Pegasus pyware targets such
occurrences byp passing malicious
messages and links which install the
necessary Spy software on the user's
mobile device be it Android or an iPhone
this isn't unique to the email ecosystem
since it's equally likely to be targeted
by SMS text WhatsApp Instagram or even
the most secure messaging apps like
signal and threa once the malicious
links are clicked a spyware package is
downloaded and installed on the device
after the spyware is successfully
installed the perpetrator who sent the
payload to the victim can monitor
everything the user does Pegasus can
collect private emails passwords images
videos and every other piece of
information that passes to the device
Network all this data is transmitted
back to the central server where the
primary spying organization can monitor
the activities at a granular level this
is not even surface level since complex
Spy software like Pegasus can access the
root files on our mobiles these root
files hold information that is crucial
to the working of the Android and iOS
operating systems leaking such private
information is a massive blow to the
security and the privacy of an
individual the information that may seem
trivial like the name of your Wi-Fi
connection or the last time you ordered
an item from Amazon are indeed all
valuable information this exploitation
is primarily possible due to the zero
day vulnerabilities known as bugs in the
software development process the zero
day bugs are the ones that have just
been discovered by some independent
security company or a researcher once
they are found reporting these
vulnerabilities to the developer of the
platform which would be either Google
for Android or Apple for iOS is the
right thing to do however many such
critical bugs make their way onto the
dark web where hackers can use them to
create exploits these exploits are then
sent to innocent users with a link or a
message like we had discussed before
Pegasus was able to affect the latest
devices with the all the security
patches installed but some bugs are not
reported to the developers or just can
cannot be fixed without breaking some
core functionality these become the
Gateway for spyware to enter into the
system you can never be 100% safe but
you sure can give it all in protecting
yourself the one thing where Pegasus
stands out is a zero click action
feature usually in spam emails the
malicious code is activated when the
user clicks the malware link a user
doesn't need to click the link in the
new version of the Pegasus and a few
other spyware programs once the message
arrives in the inbox of WhatsApp app
Gmail or any other chat applications the
spyware gets activated and everything
can be recorded and sent back to the
central server the primary issue with
being affected by spyware as a victim is
detection unlike Crypt Miners and troan
spying Services usually do not demand
many system resources which makes them
tough to detect after they have been
activated since many devices slow down
after a couple of years any kind of
Performance Set due to such spyware is
often attributed to poor software
longivity by the users they do not check
meticulously for any other causes that
is causing the Slowdown when left
unchecked these devices can capture
voice and video from the mobile sensors
while keeping the owner in the dark
let's take a moment to check if we are
well aware of the causes of such attacks
how do users fall prey to such spyware
programs a by installing untested
software B by clicking on the third
party links from email and messages C by
not keep keeping their apps and phones
updated or D all of the above let us
know your answers in the comment section
below and we will rev the correct answer
next week but what about the unaffected
devices the vulnerable ones while we
cannot be certain of our security there
are a few things we can do to boost our
device be it against Pegasus or the next
big spy on the market let's say we are
safe now and we have the time to take
the necessary steps to prevent a spyware
attack what are the things we can go for
a prim primary goal must always be to
keep our apps and the operating system
updated the latest security patches the
vulnerabilities that the exploit Target
are often discovered by developers from
Google and apple which send the security
patches quickly this can be done for
individual apps as well so keeping them
updated is of utmost importance while
the most secure devices have fallen pre
to Pegasus as well a security patch from
developers may help in minimizing the
damage at a later stage or maybe negate
the entire spyware platform Al together
another big factor is the spread of
malware is the trend of sideloading
Android applications using do APK files
downloading such apps from a third party
website have no security checks involved
and are mostly responsible for adware
and spare invasions on user devices
avoiding the side loading of apps would
be a major step in protecting yourself
we often receive spam emails or texts
from people we may not know on social
medias they are accompanied with links
that allow malware to creep into our
device we should try to follow the
trusted websites and not click on any
links that redirect us to unknown
domains spiver is a controversial
segment in governance while the
ramifications are pretty extreme in
theory it severely impacts user privacy
against authoritarian regimes sufficient
resources and a contingent plan can
alter the false veale of democracy all
together even if our daily life is
rather simplistic we must understand
that privacy is not about what we have
to hide instead it portrays the things
we have to protect it stands for
everything we have to share with the
outside world both theorically and
literally hey everyone today we look at
the hack which took the World by storm
and affected multiple governments and
corporations the solar winds attack the
global statistics indicate that upward
of 18,000 customers have been affected
potentially needing billions to recover
the losses incurred before we have a
look at this hack Make sure to subscribe
to our Channel and hit the notification
Bell to never miss an update from Simply
learn the date is December 8th 2020
firei a global leader in company
specializing in cyber security released
a blog post that caught the attention of
the entire it Community a software known
as Orion which was developed by solar wi
Incorporated had become a victim of a
remote access Trojan or a rat the breach
was estimated to be running since the
spring of 2020 and went virtually
unnoticed for months the reveal sent the
develop of the Orion software into a
frenzy as they quickly released a couple
of hot fixes for their platform in order
to mitigate this threat and prevent
further damage but how did this come
into existence we first need to
understand the platform which was
responsible for this preach soloin a
software company based in Texas United
States had developed a management
platform known as Orion entering to
corporations and governments worldwide
Oran was responsible for the monitoring
and management of it Administration this
included managing the client servers
virtualization components and even the
organization Network infrastructure that
bought the platform solar winds claims
they have more than 300,000 clients
including US government agencies and
several Fortune 500 companies this
entire chain can be classified as a
supply chain attack in this variant of
cyber crime the hackers Target
relatively weaker links in an
organization's chain of control and
delivery these are preferbly services
rendered by a third party since there is
no direct jurisdiction over it
in this case the Orion platform was the
primary target the culprit however was
software updates the update server for
soloin Orion had a malicious version
attached with malware or a Trojan to be
precise this was made possible since the
code repository that handled the
software updates was breached once the
update server repository was compromised
the source code of the applications
became open to modification and
malicious code found its way onto the
software the remote access troen was
attached to a potential update nickname
the Sunburst update this update gave
hackers backdoor access to any client
that uses the correct version on its
release many clients believed the update
to be legitimate since it came from the
right source and they had no reason to
believe otherwise American government
agencies were supposedly hit the hardest
as the list of victims included the US
Departments of Homeland Security
treasury and health several private
companies like Cisco Nvidia and Intel
were compromised according to a list
published by the cyber security firm
trusk most of the companies had issued
quick updates to fix these
vulnerabilities introduced by the
software while the actual perpetrators
have never been found it is believed
that this was an act of crossborder
corporate Espionage conducted by state
sponsored hackers either from Russia or
China before we move forward let's take
a recap of the things we learned what
category of malware was responsible for
the solar wind hack was it one a virus a
remote access Trojan a a spyware or a
worm let us know your answers in the
comment section right away and we will
reveal the correct answer in a week
coming to possible reparations the Biden
government has launched a full
investigation on the effects and the
repercussions of this breach there are a
couple of things that we as consumers
must always tend to when working our way
through the worldwide web using a
password manager is highly recommended
which can generate secure alpha numeric
passwords you must also use different
passwords for different accounts thereby
reducing the chances of a single point
of failure should one of those accounts
get breached usage of two-factor
authentication applications is also
encourag since it acts as a safety net
if hackers directly get a hold of our
credentials clicking on unknown links
transmitted via emails is also a strict
no as is installing applications from
unverified sources the solar winds hack
is estimated to cost the parent company
nearly 18 million as reparations making
it one if not the biggest hacks in
cyberspace history as recently as of
July 2021 the hackers access some us
attorneys Microsoft 365 email accounts
as part of the attack criminal
organizations like the FBI and CIA are
determined to figure out the culprits
responsible for this debacle however the
intricacy and the full extent of the
breach makes it a way more complicated
job than it looks on paper the day is
26th February
20122 the world is hit with breaking
news that Russian State tv channels have
been hacked by anonymous
a activist Collective and movement who
have made a name taking part in multiple
Cyber Wars in the past decade this was
in response to the Russian aggression on
Ukrainian territory in the hopes of
annexation Anonymous hacked the Russian
State TV networks to combat propaganda
in Russia and highlight the damage to
life Meed out by the Kremlin in Ukraine
they also hacked 120,000 Russian troops
personal information and the Russian
Central Bank stealing 35,000 files this
served as a clear indicator of how cyber
War can change the momentum in battle
something which people had never seen so
closely so what is cyber War a digital
assault or series of strikes or hacks
against a country is sometimes referred
to as a cyber War it has the ability to
cause havoc on government and civilian
infrastructure as well as disrupted
Central systems causing State harm and
even death in this day and age the
internet plays a bigger role than just
watching videos and learning content
it's where you have your personal data
and carry Financial transactions so
rather than resorting to physical
violence Cyber Wars become the new means
to cause Havoc considering the
vulnerability of the data passing
through the internet in most
circumstances cyber warfare involves a
nation state attacking another in
certain cases the assaults are carried
out by terrorist organizations or
non-state actors pursuing a hostile
nation's aim in June 2021 Chinese
hackers targeted organizations like
Verizon to secure remote access to their
networks stuck net was a computer worm
designed to attack Iran's nuclear
facilities but evolved and expanded to
many other industrial and energy
producing sites in
2010 since the definition of cyber war
is so vague applying rules and sanctions
based on digital assault is even tougher
making the field of cyber warfare a
lawless land not bound by any rules or
policies there are multiple ways in
which these attacks can be carried out a
major category of Cyber attack is
espionage Espionage entails monitoring
other countries to steal critical
Secrets this might include compromising
vulnerable computer systems with bot
Nets or spear fishing attempts before
extracting sensitive data in cyber
warfare the next weapon in cyber war is
sabotage government agencies must
identify sensitive data and its dangers
if it is exploited Insider threats such
as disgruntled or irresponsible
Personnel or government staff with t to
the attacking country can be used by
hostile countries or terrorists to steal
or destroy information by overwhelming a
website with bogus requests and forcing
it to handle them denial of service
attacks prohibit real users from
accessing it attacking parties may use
this form of assault to disrupt key
operations and systems and prevent
citizens military and security officials
and research organizations from
accessing sensitive websites but what
benefits does Cyber War offer in
contrast to traditional physical Warfare
the most important Advantage is the
ability to conduct attacks from anywhere
globally without having to travel
thousands of miles as long as the
attacker and Target are connected to the
internet organizing and launching Cyber
Wars is relatively less tedious Than
Physical Warfare people living in or
battling for a country are subjected to
propaganda attacks and an attempt to
manipulate their emotions and thoughts
digital infrastructure is highly crucial
in today to's modern world starting from
communication channels to Secure Storage
servers crippling a country's footprint
and control on the Internet is very
damaging but what are some of the ways
we as Citizens protect ourselves in the
case of a cyber war in the unfortunate
event that your country is involved in
Warfare be sure to fact check every
piece of information and follow only
trusted sources in that frame of time
even conversations online should be
limited to a need to know basis
considering propaganda campaigns have
the power to influence the tide of War
drastically it is highly crucial to
follow basic security guidelines to
secure our devices like regularly
updating our operating systems
occasionally running full system
antivirus scans Etc if your country or
organization is being attacked having
devices segregated in a network goes a
long way in bolstering
security try to avoid sharing a lot of
personal data online in this era of
Instagram and Facebook divulging private
information can be detrimental to
keeping a secure firewall for your data
the more information an attacker has
access to the higher his chances of
being able to devise a plan to
infiltrate defenses in this video we
bring you the top 10 computer hacks of
all time but before we begin if you're
new here and haven't subscribed already
make sure to hit the Subscribe button
and the bell icon for interesting Tech
videos every day let's see what we have
at number 10 from April 27 to 2007
Estonia the European country faced a
series of cyber attacks that lasted for
weeks this happened when the Estonian
Gman desided to move the bronze soldier
from Talent Center to a less prominent
military cemetery located on the city's
outskirts unprecedented levels of
internet traffic took down Estonian
Banks online services media Outlets
broadcasters and government bodies
botnet sent massive waves of spam and
vast amounts of automated Online
requests according to researchers the
public faed dos attacks there were
conflicts to edit the English language
version of The Bronze soldiers Wikipedia
page as well although there is no
confirmation Russia is believed to be
behind these cyber attacks that largely
crippled the Estonian Society let's now
move on to the next attack on December
23rd 2015 several parts of Ukraine
witnessed a par outage and this was not
a typical blackout it was indeed the
result of a Cyber attack Information
Systems of three energy distribution
companies in Ukraine were compromised it
is the first known Victorious Cyber
attack on a par grid it is said that
here hackers sent out fishing emails to
the power companies 30 substations were
Switched Off and about 230,000 people
were left in the dark for about 1 to 6
hours us investigators believed that
Russia based hackers were responsible
for this experts have warned that other
countries could also be vulnerable to
such attacks let's see what we have at
number eight in the year 199 1999 a
Cyber attack caused a 21-day shutdown of
NASA computers unbelievable isn't it the
hacker was none other than the then
15-year-old Jonathan James he first
penetrated US Department of Defense
division's computers and installed a
backd door on its servers this allowed
him to intercept more than a thousand
government emails including the ones
containing usernames and passwords this
helped James steal a piece of NASA
software and crack the NASA computers
that the International Space Station
which cost a space exploration agency's
$41,000 as systems were shut down for 3
weeks he was the first person to carry
out a computer hack against the American
space agency let's now move on to the
next attack in late November 2014 there
was a leak of confidential data from the
film studio of Sony Pictures information
about Sony Pictures employees their
emails copies of the then unreleased
Sony films future propositions and other
crucial social data were leaked this
Cyber attack was carried out by a hacker
group named Guardians Of Peace so what
did the hackers want well they demanded
that
so